Hallo, hier ist Chaosradio Express, Ausgaben Nummer 159. Mein Name ist Tim Pritlove und heute tauchen wir in die Gesellschaft ein. Wurde immer wieder Zeit. Nicht, dass wir das hier sonst nicht tun würden, aber man kann das auch nicht häufig genug betonen, dass der Untertitel von diesem Podcast Technik, Kultur, Gesellschaft lautet und ist und auch so gemeint ist, sprich der Themenmix der Macht und gesellschaftliche Aspekte halte ich hier auch genauso für genauso wichtig, wie das Einsteigen in große Details von Technologie. Na ja, eine Rede kurzer Sinn. Heute geht es um Nachrichtendienste und wollen wir ein bisschen nachforschen, was es denn damit eigentlich auf sich hat. Und ich begrüße Andreas, Andreas Lehner, hallo. Willkommen bei Chaosradio Express. It has been a while.
Ganz schön lange sogar.
Ja, wir haben gerade mal nachgeguckt, letzte Sendung und interessanterweise sogar die einzige Sendung, ich weiß gar nicht warum eigentlich, die wir bisher hier gemacht haben, ist Chaosradio Express Nummer 51, haben wir auch einen schönen sperrigen Titel uns damals irgendwie einfallen lassen, Vorratsdaten, Speicherung, Anonymität, digitale Freiräume. Das war so ein bisschen so ein Rundumschlag, wenn ich mich recht erinnere, so über alles mögliche, irgendwie, weil wir am Anfang glaube ich über Anonymizer reden, aber dann ist es dann doch irgendwie in eine andere Richtung gegangen. In gewisser Hinsicht hat die Sendung wenig an Aktualität verloren. Damals, Ende 2007, denke ich, war auch noch gar nicht absehbar, wie nah wir eigentlich so vor der Explosion dieser Thematik in der Öffentlichkeit stehen.
Ja, und das, denke ich, hat sich ganz gut gezeigt, wie, ja, wie, welches Gewicht das Ganze auch gesellschaftlich hat, diese technologische Idee der Vorratsdatenspeicherung, also der Vollüberwachung, der Telekommunikation auf Basis der Metadaten, nicht der Inhalte. Und das Bundesverfassungsgericht hat ja auch in seinem Urteil entsprechend deutlich gemacht, welche, welche Bedeutung das für sie hat. Genauso wie wir dann ja auch in der, in dem Urteil zu den, zur Online-Überwachung gesehen haben, dass also die, die technologischen Mittel, die eingeführt werden, einfach immer mehr in das Leben des Einzelnen eingreifen und immer weiter aber auch Raum greifen in die Privatsphäre hinein. Und ich denke, das ist auch ein ganz guter, ganz gute Verbindung zum heutigen Thema, weil Nachrichtendienste eigentlich auch nichts anderes machen, als in die persönliche Freiheit eingreifen. Und damit sind wir ja auch wieder in dieser schönen Schere zwischen Sicherheit und Freiheit. Und der Frage, wo ist also die Abwägung zwischen den beiden Polen und wo ist die gesellschaftliche Linie, die ja doch meiner Auffassung nach eher in Richtung Sicherheit als in Richtung Freiheit greift. Und vielleicht erleben wir aber auch jetzt, das wäre ja ganz schön, wenn wir das nächste Mal in zweieinhalb Jahren zusammentreffen, dann auch so ein bisschen eine Zeitenwende erleben, dass es eben hingeht auch mehr zu den bürgerlichen Freiheiten im Informationszeitalter.
Bist du da optimistisch?
Ach, ich denke, das ist einfach dieser Konflikt zwischen neopoben und neophilen Leuten, die der alten Ordnung verhaftet sind und diejenigen, die aber auch lernen, mit der neuen Ordnung umzugehen. Ich habe ein sehr schönes Buch zum Geburtstag bekommen. Man gibt mir immer sehr viele Bücher, das freut mich auch immer. Und eins der Bücher, die ich dieses Mal bekommen, war Payback über die Kontrolle und die Wiedererlangung derselben in der Informationsgesellschaft von Frank Schirmer. Und er beschreibt darin halt so das Problem der Informationsgesellschaft auch als Überforderung des Einzelnen, aber eben auch die Veränderung, die unser Gehirn durchmacht. Dass es also tatsächlich beobachtbare Veränderungen gibt, nicht nur im Bereich der Kurzzeitaufmerksamkeit oder auch der längerfristigen Konzentration, sondern auch grundlegende Techniken wie das Lesen verändern sich. Es ist einfach was ganz anderes, ob ich einen 2000 Seiten Wälzer irgendwo im Park lese oder ob ich vor einem Computer sitze und immer wieder diese Info-Häppchen lese, die natürlich auch unsere Aufmerksamkeit zerteilen. Also beispielsweise Twitter, wo du einfach nur noch in so kurzen Aufmerksamkeits-Häppchen gefüttert wirst, wo aber auch die Maschine natürlich ständig deine Aufmerksamkeit verlangt in unterschiedlicher Intensität zu beispielsweise SMS. Aber es ist ja doch immer so ein Guck mal her, guck mal her, guck mal her. Und ich denke, die Generation, die jetzt aber nachfolgt, wird einfach und zumindest aus empirischer Beobachtung scheint mir das auch so, wird ganz anders mit diesen Dingen umgehen. Genauso wie wir ganz anders mit diesen Maschinen umgehen als unsere Elterngeneration, wird ein anderer Umgang damit sein und damit aber auch eine andere Selbstverständlichkeit, wo die Grenzen liegen und dass ja viele auch erkennen werden, wo sind die Grenzen, bis zu denen ich gehen will, vielleicht auch durch schlechte Erfahrungen. Da ist die Frage, was kann man dafür tun, um das zu flankieren, um zu verhindern, dass sie auf die Nase fallen. Als Beispiel fällt mir hier ein, dass man vielleicht in Schulen Leuten beibringt, dass sie nicht ihre Bilder, wie sie betrunken, auf Partys umherlaufen, in irgendwelche Social-Web-Sites einpflegen, die später der Personalchef sieht. Das ist jetzt ein sehr strapaziertes Beispiel, aber dass es eben sehr viele Dinge geben wird, wo diese Balance neu gefunden wird, wo einerseits die Generation nach uns sagt, na dann steht das halt im Netz, was kümmert es mich? Und andererseits sagt, na aber hier ist eine klare Grenze und ich denke, das wird einfach ein Prozess sein, der sich zeigen wird, wo das sich rauskristallisiert. Und ich habe immer noch Hoffnung, dass es da auch irgendwann so einen neuen Umgang mitgeben wird, wo auch immer der hingehen wird. Und dass da aber auch gewisse Frei- und Schutzer immer einfach bleiben werden, weil es anders gar nicht mehr möglich ist.
Um dann mal kurz gleich mal einzuhaken, also gerade so diese Diskussion mit Medienkompetenzvermittlung in den Schulen etc. Ich bin mir da gar nicht so sicher, ob das wirklich so hilfreich oder auch so notwendig ist. Und gerade so dieses Lieblingsbeispiel mit Ich-Kotzend-auf-der-Party-neulich, was ja so ein bisschen der Klassiker ist. Was es ja auch gab, was es auch sicherlich auch in Zukunft immer noch geben wird und so. Ich denke, dass allerdings die nachwachsenden Generationen das jetzt eigentlich auch schon ganz gut verinnerlicht haben. Oder sie zumindest auf einen guten Weg hin. Also ich glaube sozusagen an die automatische Lernfähigkeit. Also immer wenn solche Diskussionen aufkommen mit wir müssen unseren Jugendlichen mehr das Internet beibringen, da brauchen wir doch nur auf unsere Zeit zu schauen und wissen, dass das eigentlich ein Widerspruch in sich ist. Weil erst einmal bringt man sich, wenn man jung ist, das selbst sehr viel besser bei und das findet auch statt. Und was soll da bitte die übernächste Generation, also die vorherige Generation der Nachkommenden da eigentlich noch erzählen?
Eigentlich nur eben die schlechten Erfahrungen, die man möglicherweise gemacht hat, damit andere die Fehler nicht wiederholen. Auf der anderen Seite, auch als Kind fällt man halt mal auf die Knie und tut sich weh und nur so lernt man laufen. Und trotzdem kann man dem Kind 15 mal sagen, fall nicht auf die Nase, das wird wehtun, das bringt halt nichts. Und auf der anderen Seite wird sich dann vielleicht auch einfach irgendwann so ein Gleichgewicht einstellen, dass es allen egal ist, wenn es Bilder gibt, wie man Kotzen auf der Party hängt, weil das normal geworden ist, so wie es inzwischen völlig okay ist, dass die First Lady der Bundesrepublik ein Tattoo trägt.
Ja, das denke ich auch, dass in gewisser Hinsicht auch die Gesellschaft mal lernt, zwischen einem Privatleben und einem öffentlichen Auftreten zu unterscheiden, auch wenn beides in irgendeiner Form sichtbar gemacht wird durch so ein universalen Netz. Kann auch sein, dass das funktioniert. Aber das ist jetzt nicht unsere eigentliche Fragestellung hier, und das haben wir auch schon im anderen Podcast thematisiert, sondern wir wollten eigentlich mal so ein bisschen mehr auf die konkrete Strukturen schauen, die sich so in den Gesellschaften und Staatsformen etabliert haben, um unser aller Sicherheit und Wohl sicherzustellen. Der Name ist ja schon gefallen, Nachrichtendienste. Du beschäftigst dich da ja auch schon ein bisschen länger mit der Thematik. Warum eigentlich?
Ach, primär aus dem Interesse heraus, weil es gerade in Deutschland einfach vor dem Hintergrund des Nationalsozialismus eine klare Trennung gab. Überall sonst und insbesondere während der Zeit des Nationalsozialismus gab es eine Verknüpfung zwischen Polizei und Geheimdiensten. Das sehen wir halt in sehr vielen anderen Staaten auch, also insbesondere in weniger demokratischen, dass also mit nachrichtendienstlichen Mitteln gewonnene Informationen, auf das können wir vielleicht auch noch mal einigen im Detail, verwendet werden in Strafprozessen. Und dann immer die Frage ist, wie weit ist diesen Informationen zu vertrauen, wie weit sind die belegbar, wie weit sind die widerlegbar. Da wird dann immer das Argument des Quellenschutzes zitiert, warum zum Beispiel Zeugen nicht auftreten können, Belastungszeugen, weil sie damit ja als Agent enttarnt wären und das wäre nicht möglich. Und daraus hat, denke ich, die junge Bundesrepublik schon gelernt, dass man gesagt hat, man trennt das sehr deutlich, das Trennungsgebot, das verfassungsmäßige, das wir haben, das also vorsieht, dass es im Bereich der Vorfeldermittlungen Nachrichtendienste gibt, die aber keine Strafverfolgung machen und dann nachgelagert auf polizeilicher Ebene die tatsächliche Strafverfolgung stattfindet und dass das getrennt blieb und es meiner Meinung nach auch getrennt bleiben sollte und dass aber auch diese Diskussion eben immer wieder neu geführt werden muss. Und nachdem ich mich sehr viel mit der Geschichte der Bundesrepublik befasst habe, als Teenager oder auch davor, fand ich das einfach sehr spannend, auch zu sehen, wie weit passt denn dieser Fremdkörper-Nachrichtendienst hier rein, insbesondere dann auch der Auslandsnachrichtendienst, weil es da ja auch in Deutschland eine Trennung gab, in der Bundesrepublik Deutschland eine Trennung gab und gibt, dass also Nachrichtendienste für das Inland und Nachrichtendienste für das Ausland existieren. Und vor dem Hintergrund der Geschichte des Auslandsnachrichtendienstes, der einfach so von den amerikanischen Besatzern mehr oder weniger der jungen Bundesrepublik mitgegeben wurde, fand ich es einfach sehr spannend zu sehen, was ist da passiert, was ist die Wirklichkeit, was ist die vermeintliche Integrationsleistung der jungen Bundesrepublik, was ist die Macht-Kontinuität der alten Eliten. Und damit habe ich mich sehr viel beschäftigt. Und als ich dann im Club ja auch politisch tätig war, irgendwann beschloss, Politikwissenschaft zu studieren, hat es da natürlich auch sehr gut hingepasst, weil das ja immer genau auch ein Bestandteil des Rechtsstaates ist. Und was sind also konstitutive Merkmale des Rechtsstaates, wo sind Trennlinien? Und fand vor diesem Hintergrund auch eben Nachrichtendienste sehr spannend, weil sie eben ein Fremdkörper sind auf einer Art.
Polizei und Geheimdienste sind getrennt in Deutschland, zumindest auf dem Papier. Du meinst, in manchen Ländern ist es nicht so. In welchen Ländern ist es denn auch so? Fallen dir noch andere Beispiele ein oder ist das eher die Ausnahme?
Das ist eher die Ausnahme, wobei zum Beispiel auch eben die Vereinigten Staaten lange Zeit weitgehend diese Trennung hatten, die aber inzwischen sehr stark erodiert ist, auch im sogenannten Kampf gegen den Terror, wo eben auch mit nachrichtendienstlichen Mitteln gewonnene Informationen einfließen, mit welchem Erfolg auch immer das, denke ich, steht auf einem anderen Tag.
Aber so in anderen europäischen Staaten? Ich weiß nicht, wie gut du dich da auskennst, aber jetzt wo du meinst, naja, das war dann so die Änderung in Deutschland, fragt man sich inwiefern solche Modelle eigentlich woanders auch Fuß gefasst haben?
Also in Westeuropa gibt es sowas grundsätzlich, wobei da immer die Frage ist, ob diese Trennschärfe tatsächlich so stark ist, wie es in der Bundesrepublik ist, aber da bin ich mir im Detail nicht klar drüber. Das müsste man vielleicht nochmal auch mit Praktikern vor Ort ausdiskutieren, um zu sehen, wie weit dann, aber das ist ja immer die Frage, wie weit die Rechtswirklichkeit dem Soll, dem normativen Ideal tatsächlich Rechnung trägt.
Geheimdienste, hat man mal so den Eindruck, stehen so mit der Prostitution im freien Wettbewerb um das älteste Gewerbe der Welt? Ich meine, gibt es da irgendwas, woran man das festmachen kann, woraus sich das entwickelt hat, oder war das eigentlich schon immer ein Teil jeder Staatsform?
Also zumindest aus dem, was ich geschichtlich weiß, ist es immer schon ein Kampf gewesen, natürlich um den Informationsvorsprung. Wir sollten dann auch gleich vielleicht nochmal den Begriff Nachrichtendienste erläutern, denn eigentlich ist ja ein Geheimdienst. Aber Nachrichtendienst bezeichnet natürlich auch, was Gegenstand der Arbeit ist, nämlich das Erlangen von Daten, aus denen man Informationen, aus denen man Wissen generieren kann. Und so war insbesondere die Überwachung der Kommunikation natürlich schon immer Bestandteil, um sich einen Wissensvorsprung zu verschaffen oder zumindest einen Wissensgleichstand. Und entsprechend aber auch Gegenmaßnahmen. Ich weiß nicht, ob es schon eine CRE-Sendung zu Kryptographie und Kryptologie gab. Wenn nicht, sollte die vielleicht mal kommen. So dass einer der bekannteren Schiffren, der Cäsarschiffre, ein Verschlüsselungsverfahren für Kommunikationsinhalte, für Schriftverkehr ist, bei dem ein Stück Papier um einen Stab gewickelt wird und damit so eine Transposition, Transformation, weiß ich gerade nicht, stattfindet.
So eine Verschiebung.
So eine Verschiebung stattfindet, das kann Rüdi sehr viel besser erklären. Und damit eben auch die Kommunikation vor dem unberechtigten Zugriff Ritter zu schützen. Ein anderer Weg, von dem ich las, war, dass man Sklaven auf die Kopfhaut etwas tätowiert hat, eine Nachricht, und wartete, bis die Haare nachgewachsen waren, ihn dann los schickte als Botschafter, und dann dort die Haare wieder abgeschnitten. Also kahlrasiert wurde der Schädel und der Empfänger die Nachricht lesen konnte, sodass auch eine Kontrolle, eine Durchsuchung auf dem Weg zum Adressaten diese Information nicht preisgegeben hat.
Und der Sklava sich auch selber nicht so ohne weiteres nachlesen konnte.
In der Tat. Man muss also auch den Booten nicht vertrauen, aber zwei Aspekte sind natürlich hohe Latenz und geringe Bandbreite.
Ja, wobei, ja gut.
Also soweit vielleicht ziemlich schön.
Wobei Sklaven hatten sie ja wohl eine Menge, also von daher die Bandbreite ließ sich wahrscheinlich noch lösen, aber die Latenz ist natürlich ein Problem.
Aber das zeigt eben auch gleich einen Aspekt, den Nachrichtendienste haben, dass es um Kommunikation geht, um die Aufklärung von Kommunikation und auf der anderen Seite um den Schutz dieser Kommunikation vor dritten. Die müssen ja auch mit ihren eigenen Agenten im Zweifel Kommunikation halten. Das heißt, Kommunikation ist auch immer ein integraler Bestandteil der Tätigkeit von Nachrichtendiensten. Wobei wir das vielleicht, um ein bisschen zu systematisieren, mal anfangen mit der Kommunikationsaufklärung. Kernbestandteil an jedem Nachrichtendienst ist, ist es Informationen zu sammeln. Diese Rohdaten werden auf verschiedene Arten und Weisen gewonnen. Zum Beispiel durch menschliche Quellen, also durch Spitzel, Spione, das man im englischen Fachterminus human bezeichnet, human intelligence. In derselben Terminologie gibt es dann eben auch andere, wie zum Beispiel Signals Intelligence.
Also, warte mal, der Schlüsselbegriff an der Stelle ist zunächst einmal Intelligence.
Genau.
Was man ja schnell im Kopf als Intelligenz übersetzt, aber darum geht es ja eigentlich gar nicht. Was würdest du als Intelligence bezeichnen?
Intelligence ist das tatsächliche Gewinnen von Wissen, von gesichertem Wissen über irgendeinen Vorgang. Der Zyklus bei den Diensten ist in der Regel Data, Information, Intelligence. Das heißt, man hat Rohdaten, das sind Beobachtungen, sei es durch technische Sensoren oder auch Menschen, die aufbereitet werden zu einer Information. Und aus diesen Informationen, also aus diesen Puzzlestücken, destilliert man sozusagen Intelligence als gesichertes Wissen. Wobei wir da schon eins der Kernprobleme sehen, den gesichertes Wissen zu erlangen, ist natürlich sehr schwierig, weil man ja auch Verifikationsmöglichkeiten braucht, man aber schlecht nachfragen kann. Auf der anderen Seite, je gesicherter eine Information ist, desto geheimer wird sie. Das heißt, dieser ganze Apparat dient eigentlich nur dazu, Informationen zu sammeln, die immer geheimer werden, bis sie niemand mehr wissen darf. Dazu fällt mir ein schönes Bombo ein. Ein deutscher Bundeskanzler fand den, also eigentlich alle deutschen Bundeskanzler, den Bundesnachrichtendienst sehr schwierig. Ein deutscher Bundeskanzler, ich weiß gerade nicht präsent, wer es war, meinte, man könne sich den ganzen Laden auch sparen und ein Abonnement der neuen Zürcher Zeitung bestellen. Damit hätte man die Informationen schneller und gesicherter.
Echt, so eine schlechte Performance wurde da unterstellt?
Ja, streckenweise. Es ist halt auch immer die Frage, wie bewertet man das, was da kommt und wie weit können die selbst überhaupt, wie weit können Nachrichtendienste eben das, was sie an Wissen zu haben glauben, tatsächlich bewerten? Vick hat, der Vorsitzende des Chaos-Computer-Clubs war ja für die Vereinten Nationen als Waffeninspektor im Irak, bevor der Krieg begann. Und er hat festgestellt, dass seiner Ansicht nach das Ganze eine große Lüge war, was Paul aufgetischt hat. Das ist aber eine plausible Lüge war, die die Vermutlicher selbst geglaubt haben.
Also diese Lüge mit diesen beweglichen Raketenabschlussbasen.
In dem Fall ging es, wenn ich das richtig erinnere, um ein Biowaffen-Laboratorium auf einem Fahrzeug. Und als er vor Ort war, fand er einen Feuerwehrwagen, ein Tankfahrzeug. So dass zwar in der Tat die Annahme korrekt ist, dass es sich um ein Fahrzeug zum Bewegen von Flüssigkeiten handelt, dass es soweit auch plausibel war aufgrund der Daten, da aber offensichtlich keine Farbluftbilder vorhanden waren, nur schwarz-weiß Bilder, war einfach nicht erkennbar, dass es rot ist und dass es ein Feuerwehrfahrzeug ist. Und möglicherweise auch die Auflösung nicht hoch genug. Da sollten wir das Spiegelinterview nochmal nachlesen, indem er das geäußert hat. Aber letztlich ist auch immer die Frage, wie weit glauben die an das, was sie an Wissen haben? Und wo kann man das auftrennen? Wo ist es überhaupt möglich, ein Bewertungssystem zu finden? Man kann natürlich auf Past-Performance, also auf vergangene Zuverlässigkeit von menschlichen Quellen spekulieren. Aber ob das im konkreten Fall dann tatsächlich was bringt, ist halt auch die Frage, je nachdem, wie groß die Entscheidung ist. Ich denke, worüber wir gleich noch sprechen sollten, ist vielleicht auch die Zeit des Kalten Krieges, in dem Nachrichtendienste oder Geheimdienste eine sehr große Rolle gespielt haben. Und auch über entsprechendes Budget verfügten und ja auch zu sehr mächtigen Apparaten anwuchsen.
Ja, also kurz gesagt, Nachrichtendienste, Organisationen, die versuchen, Informationen zu generieren aus irgendwelchen Daten, was auch immer das für Quellen sein mögen, und die in Intelligence, also in gesichertes Wissen umzusetzen, die dann wiederum Basis von klugen und weisen staatsmännischen Entscheidungen sein sollte. Dass das nicht immer funktioniert, das haben wir gerade gehört. Beispiel Irak war sicherlich, entweder war es halt ein ein unglaublicher Fail der Nachrichtendienste oder es war schlicht und ergreifend auch die Erkenntnis, dass sie zu nichts anderem dienen, als dem vorgeben, irgendwelche Informationen, die einem gerade in den Kram passen. Und man kann dann eben sozusagen sagen, naja, das ist alles irgendwie total geheim. So, deswegen können wir uns das jetzt nicht genau erklären. Aber wir sind uns schon echt sicher und ihr könnt uns das jetzt einfach mal glauben. Ich meine, der Paul hat sich ja damals vor der UNO einfach unglaublich blamiert und das glaube ich im Nachhinein versinkt ja auch immer noch vor Scham in den Boden. Ich weiß nicht, ob er damals geglaubt hat. Ich frage mich wirklich, ob er das damals wirklich geglaubt hat. Ob der mittlerweile so sehr in so einem Reality-Distortion-Field war, dass er es geglaubt hat, wieder besseren Wissens oder ob er irgendwie von schon immer wusste, dass er nur ein Instrument ist, aber irgendwie geglaubt hat, dass so im Kontext so, wir sind ja die US-Regierung, ja uns kann keiner was, wir kommen eh mit allem durch. Was denkst du? Also was?
Ich habe keine Ahnung, aber es ist sehr schwierig, in Menschen reinzuschauen, weswegen man ja immer nur verhalten misst um auf Absichten zu schließen, was dann wiederum eine Frage der Sensorik ist oder überhaupt der Herangehensweise, wie man also weiß, was in einem Menschen vorgeht. Ich finde das sehr schwierig, ob er das geglaubt hat oder nicht. Letztlich ist es dann ja aber auch egal, weil die letztendliche Entscheidungsbefugnis und auch die Verantwortung liegt bei den politischen Entscheidungsträgern und nicht bei den Nachrichtendiensten. Ob aber die dann nur, wie du meinst, gewünschte Informationen hinkommen, also so einen Normierungsdruck auf sozial erwünschte Antworten, kann ich mir gut vorstellen. Das passiert ja bei der simpelsten Umfrage. Niemand gibt bei einer Umfrage zu, wenn er aus dem Wahllokal kommt, dass er NPD gewählt hat, sondern antwortet dann halt keine Ahnung, CDU oder irgendwas anderes in dem eigenen Bereich des politischen Spektrums oder sogar auf der anderen Seite, sodass wir selbst bei so simplen Dingen wie einer Wählerbefragung nach der Wahl für Hochrechnungen immer das Problem haben, dass es so sozial erwünschten Antwortstruck gibt.
Also um genau zu sein, für Prognosen, nicht für Hochrechnungen. Ja, da ist was dran.
Das gibt es vermutlich auch bei den Nachrichtendiensten, also auch so mit so organisationssoziologischen Aspekten werden, die sicherlich zu kämpfen haben. Und dann ist eben die Frage, wie misst man das? Und wie kann man sowas bewerten? Wobei wir da genau beim nächsten Problem sind, wer soll das tun? Wie funktioniert überhaupt die parlamentarische Kontrolle von Nachrichtendiensten in Demokratien?
Bevor wir da vielleicht mal weitergehen, weil wir sind schon sehr in so einem philosophischen Punkt angekommen, sollten wir vielleicht erst mal noch ein bisschen mehr zusammenhaken, wie es eigentlich genau aussieht. Und bleiben wir jetzt mal beim Beispiel Bundesrepublik Deutschland. Ich weiß, dass unser Hürakeis noch ein bisschen weiter heraus schwappt, aber das ist noch mal der am besten beobachtete Bereich hier. Was haben wir denn eigentlich an Nachrichtendiensten in Deutschland, im deutschen Staatsgefüge? Was waltet?
Aktuell oder historisch? Das hat sich auch verändert. Aber aktuell haben wir zunächst mal, ich würde sagen, wir trennen das einfach nach den...
Du kannst das auch gerne historisch angehen, weil dann wissen wir zumindest auch noch, was weggefallen ist.
Also akut haben wir drei Nachrichtendienste. Die sind für das Ausland, das Inland und das Militär zuständig, jeweils. Das ist der Bundesnachrichtendienst, das ist der Auslandsgeheimdienst der Bundesrepublik Deutschland. Das ist das Bundesamt für Verfassungsschutz. Das ist für das Inland zuständig, wobei es dort dann noch die jeweiligen Landesämter gibt, nachdem wir ein föderaler Staat sind. Und es gibt das Amt für den Militärischen Abschirmdienst, der MAD, das ist der Nachrichtendienst, der für den Geschäftsbereich des Bundesministeriums der Verteidigung zuständig ist. Da gibt es natürlich auch Überlachbungen, zum Beispiel, wenn im Ausland Truppen sind. Die Frage ist dann, dafür nun MAD oder BND zuständig.
Das war's.
Das war's, genau.
Es gibt keine weiteren Institutionen, die als Nachrichtendienst getaggt sind. Und haben die jetzt alle dasselbe Level an Geheimhaltung? Und was dürfen sie überhaupt geheim halten? Also was macht den Nachrichtendienst zum Nachrichtendienst? Ich meine, dass sie Informationen generieren sozusagen und weiterleiten, das mag ja auch für andere Gruppen und Organisationen gelten.
Gut, es gibt grundsätzlich sogenannte Geheimhaltungsstufen in der öffentlichen Verwaltung. Das heißt, das ist ein Klassifizierungsschema für die Schutzbedürftigkeit von Informationen amtlicher Stelle nach deren eigener Einschätzung. Wobei es da auch so Richtlinien gibt. Das heißt, bestimmte Informationen sind automatisch an einer gewissen Stufe. Und das Schema in Deutschland ist VS, Kennzeichen eine Verschlusssache. Dort gibt es dann zwei Stufen, nämlich VS, NFD und VS Vertraulich. NFD heißt nur für den Dienstgebrauch, wird aber auch gerne abgekürzt als nur für dich, also Retronym. Das heißt, die Kenntnisnahme durch Unbefugte kann die Interessen der Bundesrepublik oder eines ihrer Länder nachteilig sein. Was auch immer das heißen mag, das ist ja auch sehr schwammig. Das ist sozusagen die niedrigste Stufe. Und das ist ein relativ großer Teil von Informationen, der dort entsprechend gekennzeichnet wird. Die nächste Stufe ist die Weitergabe an Dritte, die nicht entsprechend in so einer Geheimhaltungsstufe sind. Das heißt, es gibt Berechtigungen, Berechtigungsstufen. Nach dem Sicherheitsüberprüfungsgesetz können Personen mit diesen Freigaben sozusagen versehen werden, dass sie das Recht haben, Verschlusssachen oder geheimhaltungsbedürftiges Material bis zu einem gewissen Schutzgrad einzusehen. Wobei da zusätzlich in der Regel noch das need to know kommt. Also muss diese Person wirklich die Kenntnis haben. Es ist nicht ein Automatismus, wenn ich in dieser Stufe bin, darf ich automatisch alles Material in dieser Stufe sehen, sondern habe ich eine Notwendigkeit, dieses Material zur Kenntnis zu nehmen, für mein ordnungsgemäßes Handeln in der Position, in die ich eingestuft bin.
Aber auch wenn es jetzt sozusagen noch nicht Verschlusssache ist, ist es ja auch nicht so, dass ich jetzt jede anfallende Information gleich in die Öffentlichkeit tragen darf. Also so eine gewisse Grundgeheimhaltung gibt es ja sicherlich auch.
Gut, da geht es natürlich auch um den Datenschutz. Also beispielsweise gibt es natürlich Material, das nicht nach außen getragen werden darf, was grundsätzlich ja alles betrifft, eben Umgang mit Ämtern. Aber es gibt dort eben so eine Abstufung, dass man sagt, naja, hier gibt es eben dieses Klassifizierungsschema. Um dazu Zugang zu erhalten, muss die Integrität im Rahmen einer Sicherheitsüberprüfung verifiziert werden.
Hast du mal ein Beispiel für so eine niedrig angelegte Geheimsache, wo man jetzt VS, NFD nur für dich draufschreiben würde, was so typisch ist und vielleicht auch verständlich?
Zum Beispiel im Geschäftsbereich des Bundesministeriums der Verteidigung gibt es Vorgaben über gewisse Abläufe, die sind NFD. Wenn man sagt, naja, die Weitergabe könnte die Interessen der Bundesrepublik nachteilig gefährden oder beeinträchtigen, wenn bekannt würde, wie wir, was weiß ich, Flugzeuge in der Luft auftanken. Oder wie Materialtransporter stattfinden, warum auch immer. Inzwischen wird allerdings, also im Beispiel des...
Reisepläne von Politikern?
Die dürften sogar wahrscheinlich VHS-vertraulich sein. Inzwischen, also es gab diesen BND-Untersuchungsausschuss, der war sehr interessant. Das war ein Joke unter Journalisten, die gewitzelt haben, dass inzwischen auch das Klopapier des Ausschusses, VSNFD, gestempelt wird. Genau, da ist halt auch immer die Frage, grundsätzlich gilt, dass eine nachträgliche Hochstufung nicht stattfinden soll.
Also wenn es einmal in eine gewisse Sicherheitsklasse eingeführt wurde, dann soll es dort auch verbleiben.
Genau.
Das heißt, man sollte sich im Umkehrschluss vorher Gedanken darüber machen.
Was halt auch wiederum dazu führt, dass das Material oftmals höher eingestuft wird, als es wirklich ist. Weil bevor man sich dann im Nachhinein irgendwie die Gefahr aussetzt, kritisiert zu werden, weil man nicht eine entsprechende Schutzstufe gewählt hat, stuft man es halt lieber eins höher. Was halt aber auch dazu führt, dass der Personenkreis, der erkenntnis erlangen kann, deutlich geringer wird. Und wenn man aber auf der Basis von Informationen einer Stufe operiert, kann das nachfolgende Produkt ja nur mindestens dieser Stufe entsprechen, wenn nicht, weil es ein Aggregatzustand ist, sogar mehr. Das heißt, man hat dann diese Pyramide, wo es immer geheimer wird, das für die Informatiker unter unseren Zuhörern vielleicht verständlich doch Multics, das genau so ein System abgebildet hat, wo man also nur Informationen...
Das alte Betriebssystem, wo sich dann mal Unix sozusagen von abgewendet hat und gesagt hat, wir machen das anders?
Ja, und wo es aber auch Access Control im Datalsystem gab.
Das haben wir heute ja auch wieder.
Genau. Ich bilde mir zumindest ein, dass das in Multics schon war.
Ich weiß es nicht. Hab mir die Details von Multics nie angeschaut. Ich weiß nur, dass sie sich um mehr kümmern wollten als Unix, hands to the name.
Wo es letztlich darum ging, im Datalsystem abzubilden, dass Personen zwar Informationen mit einer gleichen oder höheren Geheimhaltungsstufe als ihre Berechtigung schreiben dürfen, aber nur solche lesen dürfen auf der Stufe, auf der sie sind oder darunter. Das heißt, da haben wir auch wieder dieses Pyramidenschema. Du kannst zwar Informationen nach oben geben und geheimer machen, als das zu denen du selbst Zugriff hast, aber du kannst nur das lesen, was unter dir oder gleich ist. Und auch da sehen wir diese Pyramide, dass also alles nach oben wandert und stetig geheimer wird, was auch eine der, meiner Ansicht nach, berechtigten Kernkritiken an Nachrichtendiensten ist. Es wird immer geheimer, bis es keiner mehr wissen darf. Und das ist die Frage, wozu sammelt man es überhaupt, wenn dann niemand mehr ran darf? Und letztlich gibt es aber eben diese Geheimhaltungsstufen, die dazu führen, dass immer stärkere Schutzmechanismen greifen. Zum Beispiel also die Verwahrung in Aktensicherungsräumen, also in einem Tresorraum sozusagen oder eben in Einzeltresoren, dass die Vernichtung stattzufinden hat durch einen Schriftgutvernichter, der eine gewisse Sicherheitsstufe wiederum trägt. Also wie groß sozusagen der Staub ist, der hinten rausfällt. Bis hin zur anschließenden Briketierung und Verbrennung. Das macht zum Beispiel der BND für Unterlagen. Das hatten wir auch auf dem Teufelsberg gesehen. Es gibt auf das alte CCCDE slash Teufelsberg immer noch eine Postmordem-Analyse der ehemaligen amerikanischen Abhörstation auf dem Teufelsberg in Berlin.
Wo wir da alle noch mal hochgelatscht sind, kurz nachdem es geöffnet wurde und kurz bevor es vandalisiert wurde.
Das ist eine Schande.
Das ist wirklich eine Schande. Aber immerhin wurde es noch ein bisschen dokumentiert. Da stand echt eine ganze Menge interessantes Zeug rum. Ja, ich will nicht zu viel Klammern aufmachen. Du hast vorhin gesagt, okay, also Vertraulichkeitsstufen. Und die niedrigste ist nur für den Dienstgebrauch. Das betrifft also das Klopapier und andere wichtige Sachen. Die zweite Stufe hieß wie?
VS-Vertraulich. Danach kommt Geheim, danach kommt Strenggeheim. Und der Unterschied ist, dass die Kenntnisnahme durch Unbefugte für die Bundesrepublik nachteilig, schädlich, gefährdend sein kann oder ihren Bestand gefährden kann. Wobei das auch immer so eine Frage der Abgrenzung ist. Also wo ist sozusagen dann im konkreten Fall die Abgrenzung? Da gibt es natürlich auch Fälle, die dann nicht eindeutig zu klären sind. Weswegen dann vermutlich auch wieder eher eine Einstufung in eine höhere Kategorie stattfindet.
Bist du in der Lage auch noch mal so ein Beispiel zu nennen, dass man sich mal so vorstellen kann, wo das so umschlägt? Ich meine, das ist letzten Endes immer vom Fall, vom Bearbeiter, vom Kontext und was weiß ich noch abhängig, aber nur mal so von der Größenordnung her. Also NFD, okay, klar, alles klar. Das ist so, ist irgendwie, kann Spuren von Erdnüssen enthalten. Das ist irgendwie, wissen wir nicht, so ist jetzt nicht so die größte Geheimhaltung. Aber sag's erst mal, Keim, vertraulich klingt ja dann schon nach einem recht eingeschränkten Personenkreis irgendwie. Weil vertraulich, weiß nicht, wenn ich jetzt etwas vertraulich finde, vielleicht sollte ich mich jetzt nicht so sehr an den Begriff aufhängen, aber wie sehr verkleinert die von NFD auf vertraulich den Personenkreis?
Das weiß ich offen gestanden nicht. Es wäre interessant, rauszufinden, ob es Fallzahlen über erfolgte Sicherheitsüberprüfungen gibt, dann könnte man feststellen, wie viele Personen zu welchen Stufen Zugang haben, wobei ich nicht denke, dass es veröffentlicht wird, dass es seinerseits wiederum eine geheimhaltungsbedürftige Information ist, dass wir dann schon in dieser komischen Logik wiederkommen. Also die erste Stufe VS vertraulich ist immer noch so, dass relativ, nein nicht Stufe, vor allem nicht Stufe, weil geheim heißt auch Stufe 1 und streng geheim heißt auch Stufe 2 bei denen. Dass vertraulich wahrscheinlich Stufe 0 ist und NFD, weiß nicht, we don't care.
Verstehe, das ist erst mal okay. Geht dann erst richtig los sozusagen?
Geht dann erst richtig los.
Also wenn es vertraulich ist, darf man sozusagen immer noch jemanden sagen und bei geheim darf man es schon gar keinem mehr sagen und bei streng geheim muss man es selber vergessen.
Das ist immer die Frage nach der Sicherheitsüberprüfung.
Die man sozusagen gemacht haben muss, um Zugang zu haben. Persönlich, beziehungsweise die sich aus dem Amt ableitet.
Genau.
Na wer ist denn dann sozusagen auf dem entsprechenden Level von diesen Stufen?
Zum Beispiel Abteilungsleiter in Behörden, die mit solchen Dingen betraut sind, haben in der Regel Zugang zu geheimem Material. Ob nur der Amtschef dann Zugang zu streng geheimem Material hat oder auch auf Abteilungsleiter-Ebene, denke ich, wird im Einzelfall entschieden, je nachdem was sozusagen die Natur der Sache ist.
Also muss nicht mehr überhaupt erstmal jemand auf den Tisch legen können. Also irgendwie, man muss ja sonst auch noch sozusagen geheim sein, der nicht Abteilungsleiter ist. Weil sonst kann er ja gar keine geheimen Informationen bekommen.
Naja, aber der kann ja zum Beispiel vertrauliches Material haben und dadurch geheimes Material produzieren. Das ist ja wieder diese in der Pyramide aufwärts. Dass du sozusagen aus dem, was du an Material hast, natürlich irgendein Aggregatprodukt errichtest, also eine Analyse. Und die aber ihrerseits natürlich, ob der Zusammenfassung der Informationen automatisch als höher eingestuft wird.
Klingt ja so ein bisschen, als ob die Abteilungsseiter tatsächlich etwas tun. Das ist man ja gar nicht gewohnt von solchen Strukturen.
Vielleicht als prima Beispiel, um das auch mal mit dem Ausland zu vergleichen. Das gibt es natürlich auch in den Vereinigten Staaten. Dort sind die Stufen classified, confidential, secret und top secret, wobei es dann immer noch Zusatzstufen gibt.
Das ist ja eigentlich genauso wie in Deutschland.
Aber das ist genauso wie in Deutschland. Das ist in der NATO auch weitgehend harmonisiert.
Stimmt, da müssen sich ja auch halbwegs einigen. Dass die Deutschen da wieder mit irgendwie sieben extra Nuancen daherkommen.
Wobei die Deutschen natürlich da immer sehr viel...
Sie haben wahrscheinlich diese Nuancen...
.sehr viel kontrollierter sind und sehr viel näher am Buchstaben und nicht am Sinn von Vorschriften handeln.
Als wenn ihnen einer etwas sagt, für was sie selber nicht geklärt worden sind, dann halten sie sich sofort die Ohren zu und singen na.
Stimmt dich. Nun, letztlich gibt es es aber auch in den Vereinigten Staaten. Und sehr viel von Material, was in einer dieser Schutzstufen ist, konnten wir und dann auch sehen, wie dieses Klassifizierungssystem im Augenblick funktioniert, konnten wir ja sehen in den letzten Monaten, wenn es wieder auf Wikileaks gelandet ist. Wikileaks ist ja ohnehin vermutlich allen bekannt. Gab es schon eine Sendung dazu?
Nein, ich hatte das ein paar Mal probiert. Es ist eigentlich immer an Terminen Fragen gescheitert. Aber es gab zwei Sendungen beim Küchenradio, wo einiges vorgestellt wurde. Aber das kommt ja sicherlich auch noch mal auf den Tisch.
Gut, in aller Kürze, Wikileaks ist eine Plattform, die verspricht, Dokumente mit einer Geheimhaltungseinstufung zu veröffentlichen. Sofern sie noch nicht veröffentlicht sind, das ist letztlich ihre komplette Policy, wenn es geheim ist und wenn es noch nicht veröffentlicht ist. Sie veröffentlichen nichts, was schon anderweitig verfügbar ist. Und sie veröffentlichen nichts, was keine amtliche Geheimhaltungseinstufung hat. Und dort gab es auch einen Bericht über Wikileaks selbst. Den haben sie natürlich veröffentlicht. Über die Einschätzung, was sozusagen die Gefahren sind, die aus Wikileaks den amerikanischen Dienst und der Regierung erwachsen. Und da sieht man eigentlich ganz gut, der ist auch relativ weit oben eingestuft. Ich weiß es gerade nicht aus dem Kopf. Dort sieht man relativ gut, dass diese Einstufung natürlich bisweilen auch einfach eher so ein Automatismus zu sein scheint. Weil alles in diesem Bericht, das ihr so ein hätte, könnte, wäre, würde. Wenn die also das Folgende täten und dabei würden und dabei hätten, dann wäre alles ganz schlimm. Aber letztlich ist es halt eher so ein Versuch, irgendwas für die Vorgesetzten zu produzieren, weil dort offensichtlich ein Interessebestand wäre Wikileaks. Aber die inhaltliche Güte rechtfertigt meiner Ansicht nach nicht die Einstufung.
Diese Geheimhaltungspyramide, das erinnert mich natürlich sofort an, du weißt wahrscheinlich schon, woran, nämlich das, was Blumenwachstum anregt und sehr stark ist. Das SNAFU-Prinzip geht ja im Prinzip genau auf solche hier. Also es ist eine generelle Beschreibung von der Problematik von Hierarchien und der Weiterleitung von Informationen und vor allem der besonderen Problematik, dass immer an diesen Übertragungskanten dann weitere Unschärfen eingeführt werden, sodass am Ende halt überhaupt gar nichts mehr von der Ursprungsinformation vorhanden ist. Am Anfang war der Plan und dann kamen die Annahmen und die Annahmen waren ohne Form und der Plan war ohne Substanz.
Und Dunkelheit war auf dem Gesicht an der Arbeiter, was ja auch genau die Ebene ist, die tatsächlich die Arbeit leistet. Und von den Aufsehern, Managern und Direktoren kamen wir zu den Vizepräsidenten, bis der Präsident auch den Plan sieht und sieht, dass es gut ist.
Genau.
Und schon war die Kacke am Dampfen. Aber das ist in den Diensten ja auch nicht anders. Und das sehen wir zum Beispiel im Bundesnachrichtendienst. Wo nach Aussage eines ehemaligen Präsidenten auf einer Veranstaltung es darum geht, dass sehr viele Dinge zwar dem Präsidenten vorgelegt werden, aber so schemenhaft und abstrakt sind, dass es eigentlich keine verwertbare Information ist. Wenn im Nachhinein an einer Operation aber irgendwas schief geht, heißt es natürlich, sie haben das doch abgenickt. Sie hatten doch Kenntnis von diesem Vorgang. Also das ist offensichtlich auch ein Instrument, das man in diesem Bereich nutzen kann, um zu sagen, wir halten das hinreichend schwammig, um im Zweifel entweder unsere eigene Dienstpolitik zu betreiben oder eben auch Inkompetenz zu verschleiern. Das ist ja immer so ein Problem, wie weit kann man Transparenz herstellen, die halt nötig ist, um zum Beispiel Korruption oder Versagen offen zu legen. Und da ist das Argument in Nachrichtendiensten, das kann man auf keinen Fall tun, weil ja alles, womit wir befasst sind, grundsätzlich einer Geheimhaltung unterliegt und damit ohnehin nicht nach oben dringen darf. Was in der Bundesrepublik ein großes Problem ist, es gibt im Deutschen Bundestag das ehemalige Vertrauensmännergremium, die spätere Parlamentarische Kontrollkommission, die aufgrund der Abkürzung PKK und der Verwechslungsgefahr mit kurdischen Parteien umbenannt wurde in PKGR, das Parlamentarische Kontrollgremium, die im Prinzip die Kontrollierten kontrollieren sollen. Das Problem ist aber, dass die Kontrollierten sozusagen selbst entscheiden können, was sie als Berichtspflichtige achten und was davon überhaupt kundgetan wird. Und wenn es kundgetan wird, welche Geheimhaltungsstufe es unterliegt, sodass die Abgeordneten, die Mitglied des Kontrollgremiums sind, ja auch mit niemandem drüber sprechen können, weder mit ihren Mitarbeitern noch mit ihren Fraktionskollegen, eigentlich nur mit den Vertretern der anderen Parteien im Gremium, was sie offensichtlich in der Regel nicht tun, weil da ja auch parteipolitische Interessen mit reinspielen, sodass die Kontrolle de facto nur sehr schwach ausgeprägt stattfindet.
Welche Geheimhaltungsstufe ist denn diese PKGR?
Das hängt davon ab, was die Inhalte sind, die besprochen werden. Davon hängt dann auch der Sitzungszahlen ab. Wenn sie streng geheime Informationen besprechen, gehen sie in den Keller in einen abgeschützten, fensterlosen Betonbunker, was wir auch im Untersuchungsausschuss hatten. In dem ich sehr oft als Gast war, was ganz lustig ist, in Deutschland gibt es ja grundsätzlich Öffentlichkeit für solche Veranstaltungen. Man erfährt allerdings in der Regel erst zwei Tage vorher. Natürlich darf man das Gebäude des Deutschen Bundestages nicht ohne eine vorhergehende Sicherheitsüberprüfung betreten. Das heißt, in der Regel findet dort eine Inpol-Abfrage statt. Vielleicht können wir mal eine Sendung zu Polizeidatenbanken machen, das polizeiliche Informationssystem neu, in dem Daten über Personen gespeichert werden. Dort wird eine Abfrage durchgeführt, ob also Hinderungsgründe vorliegen, um eine Person ins Reichstagsgebäude oder andere Dienstgebäude des Deutschen Bundestages zu lassen. Die hat aber eine gewisse Vorlaufzeit da. Malen die Mühlen auch bisweilen sehr gemächlich, sodass es recht schwierig ist, einerseits die sehr lange Frist der Sicherheitsüberprüfung einzuhalten, zeitgleich aber das zu vereinen mit der sehr kurzen Frist innerhalb der man von seiner Veranstaltung erfährt. Das war für mich in diesem Fall sehr praktisch. Ich konnte dort hingehen, weil ich über einen Hausausweis des Deutschen Bundestages zu flüge.
Also kannst du dahin gehen in die Sitzung von dem Gremium.
Genau, dort kann jeder hingehen, denn diese Sitzungen sind grundsätzlich zunächst öffentlich.
Ah, so lange bis sie geheim werden, das ist dann wahrscheinlich nach 20 Sekunden. Dann darf man wieder rausgehen.
Das heißt, du wartest halt erst mal eine Stunde, bis es tatsächlich stattfindet, dann begrüßen sie es. Dann verweist einer der abgesandten, der Bundesministerien in diesem Fall, der vorgesetzten Dienstbehörden, dass die folgende Aussagegenehmigung möglicherweise nicht reicht. Dann kannst du sitzen bleiben, weil sie eh nichts sagen. Oder aber, dass zwar die Aussagegenehmigung in diesem Fall ausreichend wäre, allerdings unter einer entsprechenden Einstufung der Debatte, worauf die Gäste ausgeschlossen werden, die Öffentlichkeit ausgeschlossen wird.
Müssen ja immer wieder rein und raus rennen, oder ist irgendwie vorbei?
Nee, man rennt dann ständig rein und raus. Und wartet halt kurz vor der Tür mit Vertretern der Hauspolizei. Es gibt eine eigene Bundestagspolizei, damit dort eben keine Einflussnahme stattfinden kann. Das ist auch ganz sinnvoll. Und die sichern dann entsprechend dabei auch die Räume.
Aber diese Informationen, selbst wenn sie welche bekommen, in diesem Kontrollgremium, können sie eigentlich gar nicht so richtig verwerten. Sie können am Ende nur irgendwie einen Konsens, was sie so als Gesamtgremium davon halten, äußern. Und da ist dann wahrscheinlich durch die...
Regierungsmehrheit automatisch...
Ja, genau. Es ist irgendwie alles gut oder alles scheiße, je nachdem, wie die Fahne gerade weht. Das macht ja diese Kontrolle so ein bisschen ad absurdum.
In der Tat. Es gibt auch einen einzigen Abgeordneten, der die Aufgabe wirklich ernst genommen hat. Einen ehemaligen Richter, der jetzt Mitglied der Linkspartei ist. Wolfgang Nescovitsch, der tatsächlich ein einwöchiges Praktikum in Pullach beim Bundesnachrichtendienst absolviert hat sozusagen und gesagt hat, ich möchte meiner Kontrollaufgaben nachkommen, zeigt mir doch mal, was ihr hier tut.
Dazu hat er das Recht oder hat er einfach so?
Ich denke, das waren Aushandlungsspielraum, den beide Seiten da genutzt haben. Im Prinzip hat er natürlich das Recht auf Kontrolle. Wie weit das aber reicht und was davon, also was Gegenstand dieser Kontrolle ist. Sein Kernproblem seiner Aussage nach war, dass er einfach keine Ahnung hat, wie die Computersysteme da funktionieren, in denen die Daten gespeichert werden. Wie soll er da Einblick nehmen? Er kennt ja noch nicht mal die Organisationsstrukturen, wie sie faktisch ablaufen.
Das klingt ja nach einem sinnvollen Schritt eigentlich. Ob ihm das jetzt so viel gebracht hat, erkenntnismäßig?
Weiß ich nicht, aber das darf er ohnehin auch nicht kundtun. Aber es führt auf jeden Fall dazu, dass man die Debatte möglicherweise neu führt. Sind nicht Nachrichtendienste ein Fremdkörper? Also jetzt mal unabhängig davon, wie sinnvoll das ist, was sie sammeln, und wie weit das als Basis von Entscheidungen der Bundesregierung herangezogen werden kann und sich im Nachhinein auch als korrekt herausstellt, ist nicht die Tatsache der Existenz bereits schon ein Fremdkörper? Und wenn man den zulässt, in wie enge Grenzen setzt man das? Und wie kontrolliert man das? Und natürlich muss es auch durch den Bundestag kontrolliert werden, denn die bewilligen ja letztendlich auch die Mittel. Also das Budgetrecht des Parlaments ist ja auch das Kernrecht, das wir haben. Und das ist halt auch die Frage, wie kann man das überprüfen? Es gibt natürlich einzelne Maßnahmen, aber die sind immer sehr fragmentarisch und sehr isoliert. Zum Beispiel prüft natürlich der Rechnungshof Maßnahmen. Die einzige Rüge, die ich kenne, war bei der Überwachung von Journalisten, die sogenannte Journalisten-Affäre, wo der Bundesnachrichtendienst im Inland tätig war, was er eigentlich nach seinen Aufgaben, nach seinen Statuten nicht darf. Er ist der Auslandsnachrichtendienst, aber mit dem Argument der Eigensicherung im Inland operiert hat. Die darf er nach allgemeiner Rechtsauffassung tatsächlich Ton-Eigensicherung heißt. In dem Fall gab es offensichtlich Mitarbeiter, die als schutzwürdig eingestufte Informationen an Dritte haben abfließen lassen, also an Journalisten. Und um herauszufinden, wer diese Personen sind, wurden die Journalisten überwacht. Einer der Bekannten ist Erich Schmidt-Innbohm, ein ehemaliger Bundeswehrangehöriger, der ein Forschungsinstitut für Friedenspolitik betreibt im Oberbayerischen Weilheim. Und einer der, wenn nicht der, intimste Kenner der deutschen Nachrichtendienstszene und auch des BNDs, der darüber schreibt, der publiziert. Und der aber vermutlich auch aufgrund dessen natürlich auch eine Anlaufstelle war. Einerseits, weil er bekannt ist, weil er einen Ruf hat, weil er die Dinge einordnen kann. Andererseits, weil er praktischerweise auch in der Nähe des BNDs lebt, also ist er nicht so weit weg. Und der wurde überwacht. Und damit aber so eine Observation nicht bekannt wird, muss natürlich das Observationskommando entsprechend groß sein. Das heißt, die Personen müssen sich regelmäßig abwechseln, sonst fällt man in so einem kleinen Ort wie Walheim auch irgendwann auf. Das haben wir auch bei der Überwachung der internationalen, wie hieß die, internationalen Jihad-Union, die IJU, die sogenannte Sauerlandgruppe, gesehen, wo die Nachbarn später gegenüber der Presse zu Protokoll gaben, sie hätten die jungen Männer nicht als Terroristen erkannt. Aber die Observationskommandos des BKA sehr wohl, weil da ganz viele junge Menschen waren, die sich als Studenten ausgegeben hätten, mit dicken Limousinen, mit dicken Motoren. Und Unmengen in Ausrüstungen aufgetanzt werden oder in irgendwelchen Wohnwagen tagelang an der selben Stelle geparkt hätten. Und sowas kostet aber halt einen Heidengeld. Und da fiel im konkreten Fall dann wieder der Rechnungshof auf. Und er hat eben das gerügt, dass eine Observation eines Journalisten über so einen langen Zeitraum mit so einem Personalaufwand nicht zu rechtfertigen sei.
Dadurch ist es überhaupt erst bekannt geworden.
Frage. Nö, lass mich mal überlegen, wie wurde die Journalistenspitzeler-Affäre bekannt wurde?
Gut, wir müssen aufpassen, dass wir hier nicht zu viele Türen öffnen. Vielleicht noch mal so ein bisschen zurück zu den Diensten als solchen. Und vielleicht auch noch so ein bisschen im Nachgang. Auf die Frage werden wir wahrscheinlich jetzt auch immer wieder kommen, kann etwas, was geheim operiert, einem eigentlich wirklich Nutzen bringen? Das ist etwas schwer zu bewerten. Ich bin mir sicher, oder zumindest ich gehe davon aus, dass es sehr wohl auch hier und da mal Informationen gibt, die durch diese Kanäle in die Regierung aufsteigen, die durchaus sinnvoll sind, dass man sie weiß.
Das bin ich mir absolut sicher.
Und die nicht in der neuen Züricher Zeitung stehen.
Auch das.
Also das wird stattfinden. Also so komplett nutzlos in dem Sinne ist es nicht. Wenn aber schon so die Kontrollkommission da an der Stelle schon das Problem hat, dass man ihr eigentlich gar nicht alles erzählen darf, ja, es ist natürlich auch die Frage, hat die Regierung eigentlich genug Clearance, dass man ihr vielleicht auch einiges nicht erzählen darf, oder anders ausgesagt, darf man davon ausgehen, kann man sich ja davon ausgehen, dass im Geheimen ermittelte Informationen auch dann wirklich immer den Weg in die Regierung finden, oder ist die Pyramide an der Stelle nicht irgendwo noch einen Schritt zu kurz? Oder sagen, was weiß ich, vielleicht sagen die ja hier, das ist jetzt irgendwie streng geheim, plus plus, das darf ja noch nicht mal die Kanzlerin wissen.
Da ist dann vermutlich auch die Frage, was entscheidet, also wer entscheidet, und nach welchen Kriterien wird entschieden, was den politischen Entscheidungsträgern vorgelegt wird. Zunächst gibt es ja immer die Fachaufsicht über die jeweiligen Dienste. Das ist für den Bundesnachrichtendienst, das Bundeskanzleramt. Das ist für das Bundesamt für Verfassungsschutz, das Bundesinnenministerium. Und das ist für das Amt für den Militärischen Abschimmendienst, das Bundesministerium der Verteidigung. Da ist hier schon mal die Frage, wie weit findet da nicht auch so ein Kampf zwischen den Häusern statt? Also wie weit poolen die ihre Informationen? Wie weit will man das, dass sie das tun? Und wie weit ist es sinnvoll, dass sie das tun? Und wie weit tun sie es dann tatsächlich? Weil sich auch in der Geschichte der Bundesrepublik gezeigt hat, dass es natürlich auch immer ein Machtkampf ist. Eine Machtfrage, wer hat sozusagen Zugang zu welchen geheimen Informationen und kann die weiterleiten? Und wie weit möchte man anderen Häusern diesen Zugang ermitteln? Oder eben aber auch, wie weit gefährdet man damit die eigenen Quellen? Also wo ist wieder diese Geheimhaltungsbedürftigkeit gegenüber anderen Ministerien, jetzt nicht vertikal nach oben zur Kanzlerin, sondern zwischen den Ministerien horizontal? Und wie weit widersprechen sich diese Informationen dann auch? Wie weit können also Informationen verifiziert werden, indem sie bei mehreren vorliegen? Die Wahrscheinlichkeit ist ja doch recht hoch, dass dann eine Information mehrfach angetragen wird bei verschiedenen Stellen. Dass sie dann eher korrekt ist als eine Information, die aus derselben Quelle stammt und immer nur demselben zugetragen wird, der das ständig wiederholt.
Darf denn ein Außenminister zum Beispiel jetzt zum MAD rennen und sagen, hier zeig mir mal alles, was ihr auf dem Tisch liegen habt? Ist er jetzt so sehr der Chef von allem, dass er quasi alle Sicherheits-Clean-Unsister auch bekommt und sich den ganzen Tag nur durch streng geheimes Material der letzten 50 Jahre durchlesen kann?
Das ist eine hervorragende Frage.
Ich freu mich, was Joschka Fischer gemacht hat seinerzeit.
Das freu ich mich auch ganz oft. Aber ich glaube nicht, dass es tatsächlich jemand tut. Also unabhängig davon, ob er es wirklich darf. Beim Auswärtigen Amt ist noch das Problem, dass die ja nicht die Fachaufsicht über die jeweiligen Häuser haben. Das heißt, dass das ja auch eine horizontale Anfrage sein müsste beim, also rein formal denke ich, müsste das Auswärtige Amt, dann das Kanzleramt fragen, wenn sie den BND fragen wollen. Faktisch werden sie das vermutlich nicht tun. Aber bei bestimmten, naja, gute Frage, sollten wir noch mal rausfinden. Beim Präsidenten der Vereinigten Staaten ist es so, da weiß ich, da hab ich es mal nachgelesen, dass die, es gibt da so einen dicken Schinken National Security Law, den ich mir mal am John F. Kennedy-Institut in der BIP gezogen hab für lange Nachmittage im Winter, da ist es so, dass der Präsident tatsächlich unabhängig von irgendwelchen Clearances, die er möglicherweise erworben hat, oder irgendwelchen Need-to-Know, dass er halt immer Kenntnis nehmen darf, weil das so verankert ist, dass der Präsident Zugang zu allen Informationen des Apparates haben muss. Das heißt, die kann er sich bringen lassen. Da wird er aber auch nicht selber hinfliegen und in den Akten-Schrank gehen, sondern sich das Material einfach wieder bringen lassen.
Wobei er ja auch nicht sicher weiß, ob dann aufwärtig alles aus dem Schrank geholt wurde.
In der Tat, oder von den Platten gekratzt wurde. Also ich denke, heutzutage ist sehr viel dann tatsächlich schon digital. Wobei dann auch immer die Frage ist, was will man über Datennetze übertragen? Da gibt es halt auch wieder Datennetze, die entsprechende Einstufungen beherrschen für Sprachschiffrierer, die dann freigegeben sind bis zu gewissen Geheimhaltungsstufen, für Fernkopie, also Telefax-Schiffrierer, für verschlüsselte E-Mail. Und für manche Dinge gibt es vermutlich immer noch den Kurier, den man schickt.
Welcher von den drei Nachrichtendiensten ist denn so der spannendste? Also ich meine jetzt nicht unbedingt so für die Mitarbeiter, sondern so für die Außenbetrachtung.
Für mich als Politikwissenschaftler sind die eigentlich alle drei ganz spannend.
Wo ist denn James Bond, wo ist denn die Lizenz zum Töten? Irgendwie Sportboote, Jachten, Flugzeuge, keiner.
Der Bundesnachrichtendienst verkauft seine ehemaligen Dienstkraftfahrzeuge. Das tun vermutlich die anderen beiden auch. Im Bereich des Militärs wird es aber vermutlich inzwischen, nachdem die ihre Fahrzeuge nicht mehr kaufen, sondern über die BW-Fuhrpark-Service abgewickelt werden. Im Bereich des Bundesamts für Verfassungsschutz weiß ich zumindest nicht, wer die verkauft. Die Dienstkraftfahrzeuge des Bundesnachrichtendienstes werden unter der Legende Bundesvermögensverwaltung, Abteilung Sondervermögen, Referat Kraftfahrwesen veräußert über eine getarnte Dienststille in der Münchner Innenstadt.
Sind die wieder rückgebaut, oder sind da die ganzen Sitzraketen noch drin?
Ich glaube, die waren da nicht drin. Aber eingebaute technische Mittel werden da sicherlich ausgebaut. So was wie, sollte es das in dem Bereich geben, Sprachschiffriere, wobei das inzwischen wahrscheinlich auch normale Telefone sind, GSM-Telefone, werden da sicherlich rückgebaut.
Aber es gibt ja auch so strukturelle Maßnahmen. Ein Freund von mir hat irgendwann mal einen alten Polizeiwagen gekauft und hat irgendwie total gekotzt, als er dann irgendwann mal an das Zündschloss ranmüsste, weil das Ding irgendwie so krass gepanzert war. Das ist aber schon lange her, ich habe keine Ahnung, inwieweit so was noch der Realität entspricht.
Also die Autos, die bei der Zollauktion verkauft werden, bei einer gemeinsamen Handelsplattform der Zollverwaltung, handelt es sich in der Regel um untere Mittelklasse, also um ziemlich runtergekommene VW Golf oder Opel Astra mit Minimalausstattung, was vermutlich auch den Erfahrungen in anderen Bereichen entspricht.
Okay, verheizte Karren.
Verheizte Karren.
Aber keine Plush-Sofas, irgendwie Springbrunnen in der Jacht.
Nö, das ist auch eine Behörde. Und ich denke, da spielt eher die Behörde als James Bond mit rein.
Ja, Mythos und Wirklichkeit. Vielleicht nochmal so ein bisschen jeder Dienst so für sich. Also der BND steht irgendwie gefühlt für mich immer so am meisten und am ehesten in der Kritik. Ich weiß gar nicht, ob das jetzt stimmt oder woher ich das nehme, wenn es nicht stimmt. Aber vielleicht hat es damit zu tun, dass das eben das Ausland sozusagen, der Feind im Mittelpunkt steht. Und dass man ja zwangsläufig dann auch im Ausland aktiv sein muss, wenn man es im Inland offiziell zumindest schon nicht sein darf. Wie muss man sich denn das vorstellen? Ich meine, da muss es ja dann schon auch eine gewisse Agententätigkeit geben. Das heißt ja, dieses Land schickt Leute in andere Länder und die graben dann wo auch immer irgendwas aus. Was machen die denn da? Wie sieht denn so der Alltag da aus?
Vielleicht ganz kurz zur Anfangsfrage. Ja, ich denke auch, dass der BND am stärksten in den Medien präsent ist. Vermutlich auch, weil gescheiterte Operationen dort eher bekannt werden. Während Dinge, die im Inland schiefgehen, vermutlich auch eher unterm Tisch gehalten werden. Weil das halt eher noch eine Auswirkung dann auch auf die politischen Entscheidungsträger hat und sei es doch, Missstimmung im Volk, während alles, was im Ausland geschieht, eher noch ein bisschen weiter weg ist. Zum anderen ist das Budget des BND natürlich höher. Das heißt, der hat auch eher die finanziellen Mittel und auch personell müsste der deutlich stärker sein. Das sind, man spricht immer so von 6.500 Leuten, ich denke, das sind ein bisschen mehr. Ich weiß gerade gar nicht, wie viele Mitarbeiter das BFV hat. Aber es sind auf jeden Fall weniger. Angeblich um die 2.500.
Also der BND ist sozusagen mit Abstand das größte Nachhaltige.
Das größte und auch finanziell von dem, was an Finanzierung bekannt ist, das größte. Ich habe ja vorher erwähnt, dass es für Einzelpersonen, die Informationen über sich preisgeben, immer stärker so sein wird, dass sie sozusagen eine Akte über sich freiwillig anlegen, sei es durch Twittern, sei es durch Foursquare, sei es durch, was auch immer man im Netz gerade so tut, auf Social-Networking-Plattformen umherzuklicken und zu sagen, dich habe ich doch gestern auf der Party getroffen, ich trete der Gruppe heute Nachmittag in den Park bei. Keine Ahnung. Dass es also schon eine Detailiertheit ist, die Personen über sich preisgeben, die früher sicherlich in diesem Maße nicht mal Nachrichtendiensten bekannt war, wenn sie nicht sehr teure Operationen durchgeführt haben.
Dafür haben sie heute das Problem des Information-Overflow.
Genau. Das Schöne ist aber, durch diese ständige Veränderung, durch diese Transparenz, durch diesen digitalen Schatten, den jeder sozusagen mit sich schleppt, gibt es natürlich auch ganz andere Arten und Weisen, wie man Dinge durchsuchen kann, wie man also nach Anomalien suchen kann. Und jede geheime Organisation ist natürlich auch irgendwo verankert in der wirklichen Welt. Die brauchen ja nichtsdestotrotz ein Flugzeug, die brauchen nichtsdestotrotz Fahrzeuge, die brauchen Räume, die müssen sich ein Hotelzimmer mieten, die müssen Telefone mit sich herumtragen. Und für all das braucht es ja irgendeine legale Absicherung, das, was man Legendierung nennt. Also Tarn- und Scheinfirmen oder Organisationen, die in den Vordergrund treten und vorgeben, eine legitime Organisation zu sein, die aber nur dazu dienen, das Personal zu tarnen.
Legendierung nennt man das?
Eine Legende.
Eine Legende machen.
Was aber eben auch beim Budget, was natürlich auch im Bereich des Budgets stattfindet und schon immer stattfand. Zum Beispiel ist der Regierungsbunker der Bundesrepublik im Ahrtal gebaut worden unter der Legende einer Fachschule des Technischen Hilfswerks, was praktischerweise auch das Innenministerium war, die das dann in ihrem Budget unterbringen konnten. Viele der Abhörstationen sind im Bundespostministerium, finanziert worden, einfach, wo man halt geguckt hat, wo bringt man das Budget unter, wo fällt es nicht auf. Wenn im Bundeskanzleramt steht Nachrichtendienste, großer Betrag, dann ist halt bekannt, wie groß das Budget ist. Und sowas wird ja als geheimhaltungsbedürftige Tatsache gewertet, wo wir wieder beim Anfang werden. Das ist schon immer so ein Zirkel.
Sehr schwierig, da eine Kostenkontrolle zu machen, wenn irgendwie die Kosten als solche gar nicht auftauchen dürfen. Das heißt, der Beschiss ist sozusagen ein System.
Auf eine Art ja, weil natürlich selbst die Verbindungsführer, also die Personen, die tatsächlich Agenten führen, nur summarische Kontrolle erhalten über Beiträge, die sie abführen. Über Beträge, die sie abführen. Und der Agent selber entscheidet, ob er dem Spitzel, den er jetzt bezahlt, tatsächlich die volle Summe ausbezahlt, die er quittiert hat. Oder ob er sich einfach einen Teil davon in die Tasche steckt und davon nochmal irgendwie eine Woche Urlaub macht. Wie will man das nachvollziehen? Und natürlich sind Agenten auch immer so ein bisschen an der langen Leine. Die können ja schlecht jeden Tag um 16 Uhr zu Hause in Pullach anrufen. Das fällt auch irgendwann auf.
Also sie haben Geld und Zeit. Sie wären doch wieder bei der Jacht und bei dem Plüschsofa. Falls das doch alles wahr ist.
Aber dann halt zumindest nicht vorgesehen im System, sondern eher ein Artefakt.
Ja, also wenn er angerufen wird, sagt er nicht, ich bin jetzt hier gerade auf dem Plüschsofa, was fällt euch.
Gut, aber jetzt zum tatsächlichen Auftreten mit diesen Mitteln, die vorhanden sind, gibt es dann verschiedene Wege, um Informationen zu sammeln. Einer davon ist sicherlich technische Aufklärung, insbesondere die Aufklärung aus der Luft. Da geht es um unter anderem Image-Intelligence im Int. Das können wir dann auch nachher noch mal an amerikanischen Diensten durchdeklinieren. Das Schöne an den Vereinigten Staaten ist, dass es für jede einzelne Aufgabe mindestens eine Behörde gibt. Einen schönen Überblick dazu bietet Jeffrey T. Richardson. Das ist ein Forscher, der ein Buch geschrieben hat, The US Intelligence Community. Das kann man eigentlich nur jedem weiterempfehlen. Und das bringt so ein bisschen Licht, in wie viele Organisationen es eigentlich gibt und dann auch in die Aufgaben, die sie durchführen. Also bekannt ist ja jedem die Central Intelligence Agency. Vielen von unseren Zuhörern ist vermutlich die NSA bekannt, die National Security Agency, die lange Zeit ja auch geleugnet wurde.
Schöne Interpretation der Abkürzung.
Über die es wieder schöne Bücher von James Bamford gibt, The Puzzle Palace und Body of Secrets.
Aber es gibt ja, was weiß ich, 20.
Aber es gibt halt unter anderem Agenturen wie das National Reconnaissance Office, von dem die wenigsten gehört haben, oder die National Geospatial Intelligence Agency, also die Geodaten-Analyse-Intelligenzbehörde.
Also es ist ein hohes zweistellige Zahl, zumindest eine zweistellige Zahl an Behörden in den USA, quasi die Nachrichtendienste.
Also an nationalen fallen mir sieben ein, aber dann gibt es im Geschäftsbereich des Verteidigungsministeriums noch unglaublich viele. Und die haben wirklich für jeden Kram eine eigene Behörde. Und ich denke, es ist eine zweistellige Zahl.
Gut, in Deutschland ist es einfach Unterabteilung, wenn es überhaupt diese Diversifikation in der Form so existiert.
Genau, es gibt dann eben die...
Ja, aber was... Okay, also dass es jetzt verschiedene Sachen gibt, wo man sich Informationen... Man muss irgendwie Satellitenbilder auswerten, Luftbeobachtungen machen, man muss Telefonleitungen abhören und so weiter. Und dann gibt es menschliche Quellen. Genau, da gibt es auch diese schönen Int-Abkürzungen. Was hast du gesagt für die Bilder?
Imaging-Intelligence im Int.
Im Int.
Abgehörte Telefongespräche sind comint, es gibt SIGINT, also das Abstrahlen von Daten von Sprengkörpern zum Beispiel, also von ballistischen Raketen, die hinterlassen ja gewisse Spuren beim Start, also thermische oder Infrarot-Signaturen, was auch immer. Und dann gibt es HUMINT, die Human Intelligence, also das Auswerten menschlicher Quellen, was zumindest in der westlichen Welt sehr viel zurückgegangen ist, weil es einerseits teuer ist und andererseits diese Technik, glaube ich, natürlich auch Einzug gehalten hat und man geglaubt hat, wir haben doch das Satellitenbild von dem offensichtlichen Biowaffenfahrzeug.
Ja, genau.
Hätte man mal jemanden vorbeigeschickt, der gesagt hätte, hier steht ein verrostetes Feuerwehrfahrzeug, dann...
Ja, ist interessant. Das ist ein schönes Bild auch für generell dieser Technikglaube, den wir auch in anderen Bereichen finden, dass der eben an der Stelle auch ein echtes Problem darstellen kann. Aber ich will jetzt noch mal ein bisschen dranbleiben an diesem, was macht der BND eigentlich? Also was ist sozusagen das eigentliche Ziel? Wenn man ja jetzt Agent ist oder was weiß ich, Mitarbeiter, Beamter, wie auch immer man sich da bezeichnen will, Aushilfs, James Bond, dann muss ja nun auch durch irgendetwas die Agenda gesetzt werden. Ich meine, wenn ich ein Haus baue, dann ist irgendwie klar, ja am Ende will man irgendwie dahin und dazu muss man dann eben den und den und den Schritt durchführen. Wenn man aber jetzt sozusagen diffus im Waldstoch hat, so dann ist das ja, man weiß ja nicht, was man findet. Man weiß ja gar nicht, worauf man hinaus will. Also auf der einen Seite muss es ja in gewisser Hinsicht so eine Art Standard-Agenda geben, wo man halt einfach mal überall so seine Nase rein hält. Ja und auf der anderen Seite auch durch die politische Allwetterlage in irgendeiner Form eine gerichtete Operation oder eine Reihe gerichteter Operationen, die in irgendeiner Form versuchen, fündig zu werden in was auch immer. Also so habe ich das so in meinem einfachen Hirn abgebildet.
Das ist eine prima Ansicht. Das allgemeine Stochern, wie du es genannt hast, ist die Analyse wichtiger und insbesondere deutsche Interessen berührende internationale Vorgänge. Whatever that means. Dafür gibt es die Abteilung Gesamtlage, Führungs-Informationszentrum, die koordinieren und steuern den Produktionsprozess. Das heißt, die setzen die Schwerpunkte bei der Gewinnung von Informationen. Die setzen Bundesregierung und oberste Bundesbehörden durch Berichte in Kenntnis und sind auch Verbindungselement zu militärischen Nachrichtenwesen, die natürlich auch die Bundeswehr entsprechend auch Anfragen stellen kann. Dazu gibt es dann eine Lagebesprechung im Kanzleramt, wo sich die Vertreter der Dienste treffen und natürlich auch der Vertreter des Bundesnachrichtendienstes, in diesem Fall also in der Regel der Präsident, Ernst Urlau, mitbekommen wird, was sind die Aufklärungsinteressen der Bundesregierung im Augenblick und versuchen wird, entsprechende Schwerpunkte zu setzen.
Was könnte das zum Beispiel gerade sein?
Die Anzahl der Gasultrazentrifugen in Natanz. Im Iran. Es gibt mehrere kerntechnische Anlagen im Iran, die geeignet sind zur Anreicherung von Plutonium bis hin zu waffenfähigem Material. Der Iran behauptet nach außen, dass es sich dabei um die Gewinnung von Material für Energieerzeugung, für friedliche Zwecke handelt und insbesondere die, die im UN-Sicherheitsrat organisierten Großmächte argumentieren. Es handelt sich um den Versuch der Erlangung der Kernwaffen. Und das ist halt eine Frage, wie weit kommt man an solche Informationen ran? Wie weit kann man also politischen Entscheidungsträgern vor Verhandlungen mit, zum Beispiel dem Staatspräsidenten, also Ahmadinejad in dem Fall, wie weit kann man denen tatsächliche Lagebewertungen geben? Wie weit kann man denen sagen, wo stehen die? Was ist die Faktenlage, aufgrund derer ihr mit ihnen verhandeln könnt? Und dann sind wir halt wieder eben bei diesen verschiedenen technischen Erhebungsmöglichkeiten, die dann entsprechend natürlich auch wieder abgeschirmt werden. Also der einfachste Versuch gegen Luftbildauswertung ist, man baut einen Bunker unter die Erde und setzt sich in einen Keller. Dann sitzt man halt im Keller, dann können die nicht zählen, wie viele Leute sind da, wie viel kommen da rein und raus, was passiert da eigentlich?
Das heißt, es ist durchaus wahrscheinlich, dass eben auch wirklich Leute vor Ort sind und dass man versucht, so nah ranzukommen, wie möglich.
Genau, sei es durch Bestechung von Mitarbeitern, sei es durch Erpressung von Mitarbeitern, sei es durch Aufnehmen von Informationen, die die freiwillig von sich geben. Gesprächsaufklärung ist immer viel, kann man nicht irgendwie in denselben Zöckeln verkehren, wie Personen, die dort beschäftigt sind. Gibt es nicht Zulieferfirmen, mit denen man mit Mitarbeitern sprechen kann? Kann man sonst die Geschätzungen machen?
Das heißt, man muss ein Prinzip... Das ist vielleicht nicht die Lizenz zum Töten, aber man hat auf jeden Fall ein Stück weit eine Lizenz zum Rechtsbruch. Also man darf da, und es ist geradezu gehalten, Dinge zu tun, die jetzt hier schlicht oder straff stehen würden.
Ja, die auch für die jeweiligen Personen im Ausland in der Regel unter Strafe stehen.
Aber im Ausland.
Ja genau, aber im Ausland.
Aber sie werden ja nicht dann hier... Vielen Dank für die Informationen. Und übrigens, du bist da zehnmal zu schnell gefahren und hast Leute bestochen. Jetzt gehst du in den Knast. Das ist ja sozusagen erlaubt.
Ja, und das ist ja auch genau der Spagat. Also wie kann der Bundesnachrichtendienst im Ausland guten Gewissens Menschen dazu bringen, dass sie ihr Land verraten? Was ist sozusagen... Also warum macht man das? Und was ist die Güterabwägung? Und sind die sich dessen bewusst, was sie dort tun? Ein Buch, was das Ganze für den deutschen Sprachraum nochmal beschreibt, ist von Norbert Juretzko, einem ehemaligen BND-Angehörigen, der mit Wilhelm Dietl, einem ehemaligen BND-Angehörigen, der als Journalist fungiert, ein Buch geschrieben, bedingt dienstbereit in Anspielung auf den Spiegeltitel über das NATO-Manöver FALEX 1962 und Franz Josef Strauß und seine Bundeswehr. Und in diesem Buch, das für die wissenschaftliche Forschung relativ ungeeignet ist, weil er alle Namen verfremdet hat, vermutlich auch als Angst vor Strafverfolgung, weil er zu dem Zeitpunkt auch schon mit der Sicherheitsabteilung und der politischen Führung in Konflikt stand. Also manchmal sind die Änderungen so klein, dass es okay ist, Gassinger, Assinger, manchmal sind die Änderungen so groß, dass es für den ungeübten Leser schwierig wird, zuzuordnen, um wen es sich handelt. Der schrieb halt ein Buch über die Aufklärung der Westgruppe der sowjetischen Streitkräfte in Deutschland und deren Abzug, was für die deutschen und für die amerikanischen Verbündeten ein Aufklärungsinteresse war, zum Beispiel über den Abzug der Kernwaffen. Wann werden die abtransportiert, wie werden die abtransportiert, was wird dort transportiert, was ist da drin? Und dessen Aufgabe in der Folge offensichtlich war, einfach Personen, Angehörigen der Streitkräfte Informationen abzukaufen oder zu tauschen gegen Güter. Er beschreibt dort, wie sie in einem geliehenen Wohnwagen saßen, mit ganz vielen Toasters und Videorekordern und sozusagen den Angehörigen der sowjetischen Streitkräfte, Videorekorder gegen Standortlisten getauscht haben. Und Videorekorder.
Und was haben die heute? Spielekonsolen?
Ich hab keine Ahnung. Das ist eine gute Frage. Erich Schmidt Inbum hat berichtet, ihm sei ein Kopierer und eine Einbauküche angeboten worden.
Also, im Wesentlichen ist es dann wahrscheinlich Geld, was da die Dinge in Bewegung bringen.
Offensichtlich sind es materielle Werte, die in Bewegung kommen. Die Frage ist, was sind die Summen, die tatsächlich über den Tisch gehen? Und was ist in dem Budget? Also, da sind sicherlich die Vereinigten Staaten besser in der Lage, das zu tun, weil sie einfach ihr Geld drucken. Und ich weiß nicht, wie groß das Budget des BND für solche Ausgaben tatsächlich ist und wie viel Geld dann in technische Aufklärung läuft. Einer der Aspekte, der sicherlich geholfen hat, ist die Verbreitung von, da wären wir wieder bei unserer letzten Sendung, von EWSD, dem elektronischen Wählsystem digital von Siemens, wo es Berichte gab, nach denen Mitarbeiter von Siemens zeitgleich auch im Dienst des BND waren und umgekehrt, sodass insbesondere der Siemens-Bereich, der sich mit Abhörtechnik befasst, Voice-and-Data-Recording, sehr guten Zugang zu den Nachbarn hatte und umgekehrt, die auch räumlich sehr nahe beieinander saßen, also zwei Stationen S-Bahn. Und im Iran immer noch dieses Telefonsystem eingesetzt wird, das heißt, möglicherweise hat auch das schlichtweg Hintertüren, also Wartungsschnittstellen über die berechtigte Stellen ihren Bedarf decken können. Alles in Gänsefüßchen.
Die Einführungsstriche hat man, glaube ich, gehört.
Und ja, das ist die Frage, was sind da sozusagen die Zugänge? Über die wird natürlich aber selten gesprochen, um sich das nicht zu verbauen.
Was würdest du meinen, ist so der Wert? Diese Iran-Geschichte ist vielleicht wirklich ein gutes Beispiel. Gerade wenn man jetzt das Auftreten Deutschlands in der Weltpolitik zu dieser Frage beobachtet, dann wird ja schnell klar, hier stehen weitreichende Entscheidungen im Raum. Embargie und überhaupt ausgrenzende Maßnahmen oder eingrenzende Maßnahmen, entsprechende Kooperationen mit angrenzenden Ländern an den Iranen. Das ist ja, ich will jetzt nicht das Wort Pulver fast bemühen, aber dass das eine Region der Spannung ist, das ist ja jedem klar. Da muss man nochmal drumherum schauen, was da sonst noch so ist. Russland, Türkei, Afghans, alles nicht so weit entfernt, China. So, das heißt, wenn man jetzt Kanzler oder Kanzlerin ist, dann muss man sich ja darauf verlassen, dass diese Informationen auch stichhaltig sind. Wie kann man denn das überhaupt verhindern, so auf die Schnauze zu fallen, wie die Amerikaner mit dem Irak? Oder wollten die einfach auf die Schnauze fallen? Kann man natürlich auch so sehen. Gibt es irgendwie eine Möglichkeit, mit einem Nachrichtendienst auf einer Basis zusammenzuarbeiten, wo man dem in irgendeiner Form auch vertrauen kann?
Das glaube ich nicht, ganz sicher nicht. Also mit einem Nachrichtendienst zusammenzuarbeiten, in jeder Position, mit Ausnahme möglicherweise der politischen Führung und selbst da ist es schwierig. Das ist denke ich immer ein Fehler.
Das heißt, man muss sich mit Misstrauen begegnen?
Genau, das haben wir auch in der Geschichte des Clubs gesehen, wo ja streckenweise auch Ansprachen stattgefunden haben zu Kooperationen unter falscher Flagge, also Institut für Wirtschaftsrecherchen, die gut achten wollten über die Anbindungen des Iran ans Internet, über Telekommunikationsleitungen dorthin, über die Rolle des IPM, des Instituts für Physik und Mathematik, an der Universität, an der offensichtlich ursprünglich die Internetanbindung angedockt war. Und ich denke, da kann man eigentlich immer nur auf die Schnauze fallen mit, weil die einen so lange benutzen, wie es für sie hilfreich ist, und dann fallen lassen. Das tun sie ja selbst mit ihren eigenen Mitarbeitern, die Geschichten, die veröffentlicht werden, wie eben jener Norbert Juretzko, von dessen Buch ich gerade erzählt hatte. Aber auch in ganz vielen anderen Fällen. Also natürlich ist es auch schwierig, den Dienst zu bewerten, weil alles, was man erfährt, sind immer die Fälle, die schiefgehen und nicht die, die funktionieren. Weil die in der Regel nicht nach außen getragen werden, um einerseits die Quellen zu schützen, andererseits aber auch das entsprechend in Zukunft nutzen zu können, dieses Potenzial. Während offensichtlich doch immer wieder das Scheitern veröffentlicht wird, sei es durch eigene Lacks, die passieren, oder sei es einfach, wenn man sich so dämlich anstellt, dass es alle anderen mitbekommen, wie im Kosovo, als der Wachdienst drei BND-Mitarbeiter samt ihrer Unterlagen mal für eine Nacht lang eingesperrt hat, sei es wieder Residentin Georgien, der jetzt gerade volltrunken mit seinem Geländewagen eine Frau totgefahren hat und dann dezent nach Hause beordert wurde. Die Wahrnehmung ist halt immer, dass sie ganz viel falsch machen und dabei Mitarbeiter und Zuarbeiter gefährden und dass sie das auch bewusst tun, wenn jemand nicht mehr für sie nützlich ist. Also dass sie im Vergleich zu zum Beispiel den Diensten der Vereinigten Staaten ihr Personal einfach unglaublich schlecht behandeln und alle, die für sie arbeiten. Wie weit sie das gegenüber der eigenen politischen Führung tun, lässt sich nur mutmaßen.
Trotzdem zeichnet sich quasi das Bild einer mit starken Kompetenzen ausgestatteten Behörde oder zumindest auch mit großen Mitteln, zumindest finanzieller Art, die aber eigentlich weitgehend kontrollfrei arbeitet, weil die Kontrolle selbst, der von ihr gesetzten Geheimhaltung unterliegt, sich selber bestimmen können, inwieweit sie sich kontrollieren lassen möchten. Da haben wir jetzt noch nicht so richtig Klarheit bekommen. Ich meine, die Kontrollkommission, Bundestag, das ist so das eine. Die Frage ist, wenn ich jetzt sozusagen die Regierung wäre oder Teil der Regierung wäre und ich hätte jetzt sozusagen, oder man hat ja wahrscheinlich immer ein berechtigtes Interesse, da auch wirklich stichhaltige Informationen zu bekommen, inwieweit mir mit diesem größeren Paket an Kompetenzen, Vertraulichkeitsstufen etc. pp. überhaupt die Möglichkeit gegeben ist, das wirklich zu bewerten. Würden nur die Politiker erfolgreich sein, die vorher mal in dem Apparat gearbeitet haben? Wieviele Minister hatten wir so, die direkt aus dem Geheimdienst kamen? Mir fällt jetzt nur Kinkel ein, der war ja...
Der war BND-Präsident Ende der 70er.
Und später Außenminister.
Und später Außenminister. Wir hatten den Außenminister Frank-Walter Steinmeier, der vorher im Bundeskanzleramt für die Abteilung 6, also für die Kontrolle der Dienste und die Liaison zu den Geheimdiensten, verantwortlich war. Der war zumindest gut informiert.
Aber das ja schon wieder eine andere Rolle ist. Das ist ja schon eher so die andere Seite. Gab's noch? Fällt dir noch jemand ein?
Ich find's auch grad sehr schwierig, weil auch immer die Frage natürlich ist, was sind sozusagen die Interessen auch der politischen Führung, gerade im Bereich Geopolitik. Wie weit spielt zum Beispiel Energiesicherheit eine Rolle? Wie weit ist eben die Rolle am Kasprischen Meer? Was für eine Rolle hat Deutschland da? Wenn man sich anguckt, wie der Pipeline-Bau dort stattfand in den letzten zehn Jahren, wie zum Beispiel die Westbindung der Ukraine stattgefunden hat, wie Aserbaidschan angebunden wurde oder versucht wurde anzubinden. Wie weit auch immer die strategischen Interessen gegenüber Russland eine Rolle spielen, was davon eben die Bedeutung des Öls ist, das dort liegt, der Energiesicherheit, die wir haben, was natürlich alles eine Rolle mitspielt.
Beziehungsweise im Falle von Russland die Gasvorkommen. Na gut, bevor wir nicht wirklich weiterkommen, noch mal, jetzt haben wir mal ein bisschen mehr auf BND geblickt. Da kommen natürlich vor allem diese ganzen Auslatsaspekte rein. Ein sehr weites Feld. Das ist auf jeden Fall die größte Behörde, hat am meisten Mitarbeiter, hat am meisten Mittel und agiert halt außerhalb von Deutschland. Den Rest kann man sich zusammenreiben oder auch nicht. Jetzt haben wir ja aber noch zwei, den Verfassungsschutz. Schönes Wort, da kommt irgendwie Nachrichtendienst in dem Sinne gar nicht mehr drin vor. Oder gibt es noch irgendeine interne Bezeichnung, aus der das dann klarer wird? Eigentlich nicht. Der darf dann sozusagen in Deutschland agieren und eigentlich auch nur dort. Tut er das auch nur?
Ich denke, er hat auch keine Fähigkeit, im Ausland tätig zu sein. Schlichtweg aus Mangel an legaler Abdeckung. Also der BND zum Beispiel hat in jeder oder nahezu jeder deutschen Auslandsvertretung eine Residentur. Das heißt, es gibt dort einfach einen Ansprechpartner vor Ort, der zum Beispiel auch Personal abdecken kann, Infrastruktur bereitstellen kann. Das fehlt dem Bundesamt für Überfassungsschutz gänzlich. Das heißt, die sind nur im Inland tätig. Und da ist halt die Frage, was ist deren Rolle? Da geht es primär um politischen Extremismus und um die Abwehr ausländischer Nachrichtendienste. Das heißt, die beobachten zum Beispiel die Tätigkeit von chinesischen oder russischen Nachrichtendiensten in der Bundesrepublik.
Wobei diese Kompetenz, wie die Arbeiten da eigentlich beim BND liegen müsste. Weil die ja selber so drauf sind.
Gut, ich denke, da wird es entsprechend einen Austausch geben. Also auch die Personalfluktuation, die Drehtür zwischen den Diensten ist gar nicht so gering. Verstehe. Auch im Bundesnachrichtendienst arbeiten um die 1500 oder 2000 Soldaten. Legendiert als Amt für Militärkunde. Und vermutlich gibt es dasselbe auch zwischen Verfassungsschutz und BND.
Amt für Militärkunde.
Das Schöne ist, da wollte ich vorher noch drauf raus, wie man sozusagen deren Budget findet. Es gibt einen amerikanischen Professor für Geografie an der University of Berkeley. Also UCB, University of California at Berkeley, der eigentlich sich um Fragen wie Karten funktionieren, wie also gerade so Mapping, weiß nicht, ob sich mit Bodenschätzen befasst wird, aber es geht eher so um Geografie. Und eins seiner Hobbys war es aber, von seinem Dach seines Apartments in den Himmel zu fotografieren, wo er den Himmel kartografiert hat und dort unter anderem komische Wäsche in seinen Bildern hatte und angefangen hat, amerikanische Spionage-Satelliten zu fotografieren. Und das ganz interessant fand, dass da so offensichtlich Himmelskörper sind, die nicht in den entsprechenden Datenbanken vermerkt sind. Eigentlich gibt es Datenbanken der Vereinten Nationen, wenn eine Nation einen Himmelskörper aussetzt. Spionage-Satelliten und deren Flugbahnen natürlich nicht, sonst kannst du dir ausrechnen, weil er da ist und schiebst halt die Flieger kurz in den Hangar. Und versuchte herauszufinden, wie das Budget für das funktioniert und fand dann plötzlich auch Dinge, die er aus seiner Sicht dann wieder als Uncharted Territories sieht, als Bereiche, die im Budget einfach ein weißes Feld sind und eine Summe dahinter oder sinnlose Tarnbezeichnungen, der auch ein...
So wie Amt für Militärkunde.
So wie Amt für Militärkunde, der auch dieses Wissen später angewendet hat, als er einerseits versucht hat, Armzeichen, also Schulterklappen, Schulter-Patches, zu dokumentieren von geheimen Projekten. Da gibt es ein schönes Buch von ihm mit solchen geheimen Abzeichen, die auch immer so eine Symbolik und Sprache mitbringen, um diese Parallelwelt wieder untereinander erkennbar zu machen in der wirklichen Welt. Also jetzt nicht dich, sondern tatsächlich das Buch heißt so.
Ach so, ich dachte schon, alle mal weghören. Diese Information habt ihr nie bekommen. Wirklich?
Warte mal, ich suche einfach mal noch.
Ich frage ja eigentlich nur, weil ich später dann nochmal einen tollen Link hier in unsere umfangreiche Linkliste packen muss, damit hier auch alle ausreichend informiert sind und sich weiterbilden können, wie sich das gehört bei CRE. Wir schlagen nach. Im Buch der Waffen. Das Buch.
Symbolologie, doch, doch, doch, doch. Ich wollte ja auch gleich noch was zu ihm erzählen, was ganz gut mit Rem passt.
Wie heißt der nochmal?
Trevor Paglen.
Ja, und das ist ein Amerikaner.
Das ist ein Amerikaner in Berkeley, der sich mit Telefotografie und Symbolik befasst. Und das Buch heißt I could tell you, but then you would have to be destroyed by me, Emblems from the Pentagon's black world. Und das ist ein wunderschönes Buch, inklusive eines Patches vorne drauf, wobei er den hat fürs Buch anfertigen lassen. Es gibt auch ein Interview, ich glaube mit Colbert von ihm, das sollten wir mal raussuchen, das ist auch ganz lustig. Und er hatte aber auch dieses Hobby mit den Telefotolenses, mit denen er irgendwelche Himmelskörper fotografiert hat und kam auf die Idee, was passiert, wenn ich sie über Zäune in Richtung der abgeschotteten Militär-Facilities richte. Kann ich da nicht auch einfach sechs Meilen statt nach oben durch die Wüste gucken und fand Flugzeuge, die dieses Personal hin und her shutteln. Die haben sozusagen Shuttle-Busse, so wie der BND einen Shuttle-Bus hat, der das Personal fährt und der nur BND-Mitarbeiter mitnimmt oder mit Namen letzter Stand. Ich weiß nicht, ob es die Buslinien noch gibt oder ob die inzwischen alle mit dem Auto kommen. So gibt es auch Flugzeuge, die Angehörige der Pentagon Black World zum Beispiel nach Area 51 fliegen, die zum Beispiel auch diese ganze Ufologie natürlich super lustig finden, weil das für sie wieder Symbolik bietet, die man auf diese Shoulder-Patches packen kann. Bei dieser Gelegenheit hat er dann geguckt, was sind das für Fluggesellschaften und was tun die? Und fand zwei Dokumente, die ihm weitergeholfen haben. Eins davon ist die Liste der Fluggesellschaften, die Landeerlaubnisse für Militärflugplätze haben. Zum Beispiel dürfen viele amerikanische Fluglinien in Alaska auf irgendein Militärstützpunkt landen, weil da gibt es offensichtlich Anchorage und diesen Militärflugplatz. Und wenn irgendwas schief geht, ist es ganz gut, wenn man da landen kann. Esso darf da landen, weil ihre Förderfelder in der Nähe sind. Aber er fand auch Firmen, von denen keiner gehört hatte, die auf allen Flugplätzen weltweit landen dürfen. Und kam so zu seinem weiteren Buch, das er schrieb, da geht es um das CIA-Rendition-Programm, also die Entführung von mutmaßlichen terroristischen Straftätern durch die CIA und ihre Flüge zu Folterknästen im Ausland. Torture Taxi heißt das Buch On the Trail of the CIA's Rendition-Flights. Und da beschreibt er eben auch, wie er diese Legendierungen aufgedeckt hat. Und dass er dann, als er die Namen aus diesem Register hatte, im Handelsregister nachgeguckt hat und zu den Filialen fuhr und feststellte, das sind irgendwelche Rechtsanwaltskanzleien, in denen offensichtlich diese Firmen abgedeckt werden. Und es sind immer die unterschiedlichen Unterschriften, egal auf welches Dokument zu dieser Firma du guckst. Jedes Mal ist es eine andere Unterschrift. Also offensichtlich gibt es da halt einen Haufen Mitarbeiter, der Nachrichten, die diese Unterschriften fälschen und die Legendierungen machen. Aber es macht nicht immer derselbe Operator, sodass sie halt nie gleich aussehen. Und ein charakteristisches Merkmal ist aber, dass all diese Firmennamen vollständig abstrakt und sinnlos sind. Eine der Gesellschaften, die diese Folterflüge durchgeführt hat, hieß Premiere Executive Transport Services. Während der Bundesnachrichtendienst seinen Waffenhandel, also offensichtlich gab es eine Zeit lang, wo Waffenhandel durch den Bundesnachrichtendienst stattgefunden hat oder zumindest genutzt wurde, um Waffen in Länder zu transportieren, in denen man irgendwelche Gruppen unterstützen wollte, möglicherweise auch im Kontext des Kalten Krieges. Eine Deckfirma hieß Internationales Rechtsinstitut, Abteilung humanitäre Dienste. Das war der Waffenhandel.
Humanitäre Dienste.
Internationales Rechtsinstitut, Abteilung humanitäre Dienste, Tannenstraße 8, 8023, Pollach.
Du hast jetzt schon einige Male Institute genannt.
Das ist gerne. Institut ist eine Bezeichnung, die sie gern wählen. Gesellschaft ist eine Bezeichnung, die sie gern wählen. Es gibt einfach so auffällig, unauffällige Bezeichnungen, die gern gewählt werden. Mir fällt da gerade noch einer ein. Ich gucke noch mal nach.
Wenn ihr also, wenn man euch mal einen Anruf von einem Institut oder einer Gesellschaft, lieber nochmal nachfragen.
Irgendjemand hat in der deutschen Wikipedia sehr viel zum Bundesnachrichtendienst eingetragen. Und dort, da ist mir die Frage, wie gut es belegt ist. Aber das ist oft mit Quellen auch zu irgendwelchen dritten Artikeln. Tarnungen der Dienststellen ist zum Beispiel die Hauptstelle für Befragungswesen, die in Aufnahmelagern für Ausländer diese nach ihren Erfahrungen befragt. Dabei natürlich versucht auch, herauszufinden, wie geht es in dem Land zu, aus dem die gerade kommen. Also zum Beispiel Kriegsflüchtlinge aus Ruanda ist ja ganz hilfreich, wenn man die vor Ort befragt, um Eindruck zu bekommen. Gelegentlich werden die wohl aber auch als Quellen, also als Spione, angeworben vor Ort, wo die Frage ist, wie weit wird da die Situation dieser Person in diesem Lager ausgenutzt, um zu einer Zusammenarbeit hinzuwirken. Diese Hauptstelle wird auch gerne als interne Kontrolleinrichtung des Bundesamtes für Ausländerfragen getarnt. Wir haben das Amt für Militärkunde, das ist die Dienststelle, zu der Bundeswehrangehörige versetzt werden, wenn sie zum BND gehen. Die brauchen ja weiterhin irgendeine Dienststelle, bei der sie truppendienstlich geführt werden, unter anderem für Rentenansprüche.
Dass sie sozusagen offiziell Soldat bleiben?
Genau, beim BND-Arbeiten. Es gibt die Studienstelle für Auslandsfragen, die fand ich sehr hübsch.
Das ist ja fast noch besser als Befragungswesen.
Die Abhörstationen werden als Bundesstelle für Fernmeldestatistik betrieben. Nach deren Dienstsitzen ist der Namensraum der Server des Chaos Computer Clubs. Wir haben ja ganz viele Anonymizer-Knoten, die heißen dann zum Beispiel Butzbach, nach einem Ort, in dem eine Abhörstelle ist. Wir haben die Eibling, wir haben die Stockdorf, wir haben die Reinhausen, das ist der Jabber-Server. Da ist das Ionosphären-Institut, das ist die Aufklärung der Ionosphäre durch den BND. Also sie haben schon immer schicke Tarnnamen.
Wahrscheinlich haben sie dafür auch noch eine eigene Abteilung, die sich nur schicke Tarnnamen ausdenkt.
Mit Legendierung, bestimmt. In der Sicherheitsabteilung wird es ein Referat für Legendierung sein.
Wie heißt denn die Legendierung der Legendierungsfragen heißen?
Das ist eine gute Frage. Die sind wahrscheinlich geheim und müssen nicht.
Institut für Kreativterminologie.
Es gab einen Artikel in der Datensteuerer in der inzwischen vorletzten Ausgabe.
Ja, Nummer 93.
Da hat uns jemand eine Analyse zukommen lassen, nachdem auf Wikileaks ein Dokument der T-Systems veröffentlicht wurde über die Netze, die der Bundesnachrichtendienst benutzt, also die IP-Netzblöcke oder einen Teil davon. Ich war am Anfang davon ausgegangen, dass es sich um eine Fälschung handele, aber interessanterweise gibt es eine Mail auf Wikileaks politische Systems darum gebeten hat, ihr geistiges Eigentum darunter zu nehmen. Und das wäre nicht für die Öffentlichkeit bestimmt, dieses Dokument. Vielen Dank für die Bestätigung. Und dort gibt es IP-Adressbereiche, die inzwischen gelöscht sind. Und in dieser Ausgabe der Datensteuer gibt es eine Analyse über diese Netze und deren Tarnnamen, die dann zum Beispiel LVP Info Broking Network heißen, wobei LVP die Liegenschaftsverwaltung Pullach ist. Das ist sozusagen die Legendierung des Standortes. Man muss ja auch irgendwie den Standort verwalten. Also verwaltet man die Liegenschaft über die Liegenschaftsverwaltung.
Sowas muss ich mir für mein Studio auch zulegen.
Die Metaebene?
Ja, die Liegenschaftsverwaltung der Metaebene.
Gut, da fällt ja bestimmt noch irgendwas ein. Aber ja, es gibt also ganz viele Bezeichnungen. Das Amt für Schadensabwicklung existiert, falls da mal ein Schaden stattfindet. Das ist auch immer sehr direkt und auf eine Art und Weise auch offensichtlich. Das gab lange Zeit das Bundesamt für Finanzen, Bundesbesoldungsstelle, Außenstelle Süd. Also Süd verwenden sie auch gerne, weil sie in Pollach saßen, weil dort die Amerikaner letztlich...
Auch wenn es keinen Nord gibt sozusagen.
Genau, dann gibt es halt nur das Südlabor oder die Außenstelle Süd.
Aber es klingt ja so schön regional und so schön unwichtig. Ja, das ist schon ganz klug.
Oder den ärztlichen und sozialen Dienst für Bundesdienststellen. Die Versicherung hat, glaube ich, über die Betriebskrankenkasse des Bundesverkehrsministeriums stattgefunden. Da sah ich mal ein Dokument, in dem der Vorstand darauf hingewiesen wurde, dass bei einer Fusion der Betriebskrankenkasse des Bundesverkehrsministeriums mit irgendeiner anderen Betriebskrankenkasse, was offensichtlich aufgrund der desolaten Situation der Krankenkassen nötig wurde, zwei feste Mitarbeiter einzuplanen seien als Vertreter des Bundesnachrichtendienstes in irgendeinem Gremium.
Ich könnte mein Studio Institut für Sprachverbreitung Abteilung Prenzlauer Bergen nennen.
Nordost, Niederlassung Nordost. Genau, und dann gibt es aber wohl zusätzlich noch Decknamen für den internen Gebrauch, die dann aber auch wieder teilweise lokale Anklänge haben. Eine Dienststelle in Berlin heißt wohl A-Wuss.
Da gibt es dann auch keine Präsidenten, da gibt es nur Gebietsleiter und so.
Tja, wie ist das in der Legendierung oder faktisch?
Faktisch, was weiß ich. Man weiß schon, wie das ist mit den Fakten.
Gut, und das das Merkwürdige ist, das ist wiederum ein konstitutives Merkmal von Nachrichtendiensten, dass sie dieses Legendierungsspiel einerseits spielen müssen. Andererseits klar ist, dass durch diesen digitalen Schatten, den es inzwischen zu allem gibt, es sehr viel leichter wurde, sowas aufzuklären. Also das Handelsregister ist online, man muss nicht nach München fahren, man kann einfach online reingucken. Eines der Probleme, das eben zum Beispiel bei diesen Rendition-Flights, der CRE aufgetreten ist oder was beim Bundesnachrichtendienst auch passiert ist, es gibt Flugzeuge, die genutzt werden, die in der Regel natürlich auf zivile Einrichtungen lauten, also auf irgendwelche Kapitalgesellschaften. Es gibt aber Menschen mit seltsamen Hobbys. Diese Analysen, die ich mache, mache ich ja eher auch immer noch aus meinem politikwissenschaftlichen Studium heraus und aus meiner Tätigkeit im Berliner Informationszentrum für transatlantische Sicherheit. Mich interessiert halt, was sind das für Aspekte. Aber es gibt Menschen, die verbringen ihre Tage offensichtlich auf Hügeln liegend in der Nähe von Flugplätzen, Planespotters und fotografieren jedes landende Flugzeug und legen darüber Berichte an, also welche Starts und Landungen haben stattgefunden und stellen Fotos der Maschinen ins Netz, was es leichter macht, nachvollziehen zu können. Genau, Planespotter, wo beispielsweise der Präsident des Bundesnachrichtendienstes war offensichtlich, so entnehme ich der Datenschleuder, weil die Bezeichnung der Maschine bekannt war, wiederum weil irgendeine entführte Person mit dem BND-Jet zurückgeflogen wurde. Und damit Fotos der Maschine existierten, aus der der Präsident steigt und damit nachvollzogen werden konnte, was ist in der Vergangenheit passiert mit dieser Maschine, wo war die? Oh, guck mal, so ein schönes Flugzeug. Und dasselbe ist bei den Maschinen der CIA passiert. Und ich denke, das sind Probleme, an die sich die Dienste gewöhnen werden und die aber auch natürlich für höhere Transparenz sorgen, dass bestimmtes Verhalten einfach nicht mehr möglich ist. Und dann ja auch zu so etwas führt wie der Aufdeckung dieser Foltergefängnisse, von denen wir möglicherweise sonst nie erfahren hätten.
Das heißt, die zunehmende Vernetzung und Technisierung der Gesellschaft im Allgemeinen führt automatisch zu mehr Kontrolle, das Geheimen? Oder ist das schon fast ein bisschen schön geredet?
Das ist zumindest ein Wunsch. Und wenn wir uns WikiLeaks ansehen, denke ich, spricht viel dafür. Also die bezeichnen sich ja selbst zum Teil auch als Public Intelligence Agency, sozusagen als verteilter Nachrichtendienst, der aber eben als Kern ja die Aufhebung der Geheimhaltung hat. Wie gut sowas funktioniert, weiß ich nicht. Ich glaube auch schon, dass es schutzwürdige Dinge gibt, dass also Privatsphäre existiert und dass man über die durchaus diskutieren sollte. Es gibt zum Beispiel auf WikiLeaks irgendwelche Initiationsrieten, irgendwelche Frauenstudentenbünde an irgendwelchen amerikanischen Unis, wo ich halt nicht weiß, ob man das offenlegen muss. Also kann man sicherlich, aber was ist sozusagen der Erkenntnisgewinn, dass es an Hochschulen Gruppen gibt, die sich irgendwie dreimal linksen Kursen, zweimal rechts geben, bevor sie sich irgendwie zum gemeinsamen Rotwein trinken, hinsetzen? Ob das im Interesse der Öffentlichkeit ist, keine Ahnung.
Ja, weiß man zumindest schon mal nicht, dass es ein Erkennungsignal für Geheimdienstmitarbeiter ist.
Ja guter Punkt.
Ausschlussprinzip. Ich meine, gut, WikiLeaks ist jetzt noch mal ein Fass, das machen wir jetzt hier nicht auf. Auch wenn an der Stelle die Problematik ist, dass wenn man überhaupt irgendwas ablehnt, was ist das Kriterium dafür und wer beurteilt das? Und deswegen herrscht ja da zumindest bisher noch eher so das strikte, wenn es den Basiskriterien entspricht, im Sinne von es wurde noch nicht veröffentlicht. Und wobei es gibt natürlich dann auch schon so eine Abwägung, ist überhaupt irgendein Wert in diesem Dokument. Und das kann man natürlich dann so und so sehen.
Also ich glaube trotzdem, dass es gut ist, so wie es passiert, denn nur so kann es funktionieren, dass also Personen, die Informationen leaken wollen, veröffentlichen wollen, wissen, solange es geheim gehalten wird, veröffentlicht es Wikileaks, wenn es das Dokument erhält. Und das wäre ganz gut. Vielleicht muss es irgendeine andere Plattform geben, neben Wikileaks, die dann andere Ansätze ausprobiert. Aber ich denke, die sind in ihrer Rolle auf jeden Fall sehr gut und sollten das genauso fortführen. Wobei, da sehen wir auch den Streit dann zwischen diesen beiden Maximalpositionen, also die Maximalposition der Geheimdienste. Wir veröffentlichen gar nichts, mit Ausnahme vielleicht von zielgerichteten Indiskretionen, falls man niemanden loswerden muss. Und auf der anderen Seite Wikileaks, die sagen, wir veröffentlichen alles, egal was es ist.
Wobei das natürlich dann stark im Konflikt steht, eben mit dieser Frage der Privatsphäre, die du ja auch schon angesprochen hast. Also das Beispiel der Mitgliederlisten, rechtsextremer Parteien, was war das? British National Party. Stellt ja im Prinzip schon genauso eine Frage. Und ist die eine Partei da jetzt besser als die andere? Und handelt es sich hier nicht um private Daten?
Genau, und auf der anderen Seite der Konflikt zwischen Nachrichtendiensten und dem Individuum ist dann die informationale Selbstbestimmung. Warum speichern die, ohne dass ich ein Recht auf Kontrolle und Einsichtnahme habe, Daten über mich? Und das ist ja insbesondere ein Problem, weil die Verifikation nicht gegeben ist. Weswegen man historisch solches Material ja auch nicht zugelassen hat im Strafprozess, was jetzt gerade so ein Antiterror-Verfahren ein bisschen aufweicht. Und da ist halt die Frage, woher haben die das? Und am Beispiel der CIA-Folterflüge, was bringt es, wenn ich ein Geständnis aus einem Foltergefängnis in Syrien zu einem Prozess zulasse, wo vermutlich der Gefolterte alles gestehen wird, solange die Schmerzen aufhören? Welchen Sinn hat dieses Geständnis?
Nobody expects the Spanish Inquisition, sag ich dazu nur. Aber jetzt bist du mir so ein bisschen entflohen, was so diese Frage mit der Privatsphäre betrifft, auch wenn ich das jetzt nicht so zu einem Mittelpunkt stellen wollte. Aber du hast ja vorhin das auch sozusagen selber aufgebracht. Wie kann man dann sozusagen jetzt mit so einer Counterintelligence, wie ich das jetzt mal nennen möchte, an der Stelle so auftreten, dass man eben der Gesellschaft an der Stelle auch gerecht wird? Das ist ja eigentlich ein schwerwiegender Konflikt. Wie kann man den auflösen?
Ich möchte da gerne mit der Prinzipie Descordia antworten. I don't know man, I didn't do it.
Ja gut, du steckst da nicht drin, aber du betrachtest es ja von außen.
Für mich wirft es mehr Fragen auf als Antworten. Und ich denke, Wikileaks kann nur das tun, was es kann. Und damit werden sie auch die Privatsphäre in vielen Fällen tatsächlich verletzen. Und die Frage ist eher, ob sich später irgendein Mittelfeld positionieren kann und sozusagen der Marktwettbewerb entscheidet, wo geht es hin. Also wenn es ein Instrument geben wird, was ähnliche Reputationen wie Wikileaks erlangen kann, in der Leistung, die sie ja unzweifelsfrei erbracht haben, die aber andere Kriterien ansetzen, dann kann sich beweisen, ob das funktioniert oder nicht. Ich denke halt, diese redaktionelle Kontrolle ist sehr schwierig, denn dann obliegt plötzlich die Güterabwägung, was publiziert werden soll und was nicht, bei Wikileaks. Und wir sehen ja schon, was für ein Echo hervorgerufen wurde, als ein Video der Vereinigten Staaten, der Streitkräfte der Vereinigten Staaten, das geheim gehalten wurde, veröffentlicht wurde. Da sind wir jetzt wieder ein bisschen weg vom Nachrichtendienst, aber bei dieser Frage zwischen Geheimhaltung und Öffentlichkeit und Transparenz. Das Video zeigt eine Kontrolle des Personals aus einem US-Hubschrauber, die auf Zivilisten schießen. Das ist vermutlich auch keine Ausnahme. Das ist nicht A few bad apples, sondern das ist offensichtlich die Regel. Und bei diesen Kameraaufnahmen handelt es sich vermutlich auch um den Beweis der Tätigkeit gegenüber den Dienstvorgesetzten, sodass anzunehmen ist, dass tatsächlich bei jedem Kampfeinsatz solche Aufnahmen gefertigt werden, obwohl ich die entsprechende Richtlinie nicht kenne. Und dieses Video ist lange Zeit geheim gehalten worden, obwohl sogar das Militär zunächst angekündigt hat, es zu veröffentlichen. Vermutlich auch deshalb, weil ein Reuters-Journalist und sein Mitarbeiter zu Tode kamen und deswegen auch ein erhöhtes Interesse der Medien an diesem konkreten Fall vorlag. Und die Regierung hat aber beschlossen, das geheim zu halten. Punkt. Wikileaks hat das veröffentlicht und damit ja auch ein sehr großes Medienecho erzählt. Die Frage, die sich nun aber stellt, ist, warum wurde dem sozusagen so viel Begleitaufmerksamkeit gewidmet und anderen Dingen nicht? Und die Frage, die sie sich durchaus gefallen lassen müssen, ist halt, ob sie nicht in diesem Fall einen Bias hatten.
Ja, also es geht konkret um das Video, was bekannt geworden ist unter dem von Wikileaks ja auch verliehenden Titel, Collateral Murder, was breite Welle gemacht hat. Ja, und was denkst du, was ist der eigentliche Vorwurf an Wikileaks in dem Zusammenhang?
Dass sie ihre Entscheidungsregeln nicht transparent machen und nicht klar machen, wie viel Material sie gerade haben, dass sie nicht veröffentlichen und aus welchen Gründen sie es nicht veröffentlichen und was die Zeitfenster sind.
In den etwas veröffentlichten?
In den etwas veröffentlichten, dem wurde ja offensichtlich höchste Priorität zugesprochen, was ja auch okay ist. Es hat ja auch sicherlich die politische Auswirkung maximiert und im Fall von so etwas drastischem wie einem bewaffneten Konflikt oder einem Krieg ist es ja sicherlich gerechtfertigt, da auch Leute eher darauf hinzuweisen als auf die Mitgliedschaft von Personen in der British National Party, die dann einfach vom Gewicht her, von den Auswirkungen auf die Bevölkerung eine ganz andere Dimension hat. Aber es ist halt unklar, was sind diese Entscheidungsregeln? Und ich denke, das ist das Problem des Wikileaks gehört, dass sie diese Transparenz, die sie von anderen einfordern oder erzwingen, in Teilen auch über sich selber herstellen müssen. Und da ist die Frage, wie können sie das tun, ohne ihr Handeln zu gefährden?
Oder auch ihre Zeugen zu schützen, weil es ja interessant ist, dass man an der Stelle genauso argumentiert wie die Geheimdienste das auch tun und das Geheime auch nur mit Geheimhaltung machen kann, auch um die eigenen Mitarbeiter zu schützen. Und in gewisser Hinsicht haben sich ja schon zumindest die stärker in der Öffentlichkeit stehenden Zuträger und Mitwirker bei dem Projekt ja auch schon sehr in der Öffentlichkeit, sagen wir mal, als Public Enemy schon, wenn nicht geriert, aber zumindest dahin entwickelt, zwangsläufig. Muss man halt auch mal sehen, wie groß das Gefährdungspotenzial für die Aktivisten an der Stelle auch wiederum ist und inwiefern sie sich dann selber schützen müssen mit den gleichen Methoden. Auch wenn es jetzt bei Wikileaks ja nicht primär um Nachrichtendienste geht. Das ist jetzt bei diesem einen Beispiel natürlich sehr naheliegend. Auch wenn es hier nur mehr eigentlich die Armee war, die natürlich auch ihre eigenen Nachrichtendienste und auf jeden Fall ihre eigenen Geheimnisstufen hat. Gar keine Frage.
Gut, aber das, was es zeigt, und ich denke, das ist ja auch die Frage, auf die wir uns gerade vielleicht eine Ebene höher über das in der Sendung besprochene Thema auch angehoben haben.
Sag, auf der Metaebene.
Auf der Metaebene sozusagen ist doch die Frage zwischen Geheimhaltung und Informationsfreiheit. Also die Frage, wie wollen wir als Gesellschaft in Zukunft mit Informationen umgehen? Wie weit wollen wir Informationsasymmetrien, und nichts anderes ist ja ein Wissensvorsprung, zum Beispiel durch einen Nachrichtendienst, weiterhin tolerieren? Oder wie weit kann Information at your fingertips nicht dazu führen, dass sich da auch irgendwo eher so ein Ausgleich stattfindet für diejenigen, die es interessiert? Sicherlich nicht in allen Bereichen. Da wären wir wieder ganz am Anfang bei der Überforderung durch die Technologie, bei dem Buch Payback. Ich denke nicht, dass das funktionieren kann, dass jeder alles weiß. Dazu ist einfach das Wissen inzwischen zu groß. Aber die spannende Frage ist ja doch, wie gehen wir mit Informationen um? Wie geht der Einzelne mit Informationen um, die über sich Preis gibt? Und wie gehen wir mit Informationen um, die wir als Gesellschaft zur Verfügung haben? Wie kann man die bewerten? Wie kann man die einschätzen? Wie kann man die vergleichen? Was davon soll privat bleiben und was nicht?
Was ist denn dein Verhältnis zum Geheimdienst? Also für welchen arbeitest du?
Du arbeitest, wie ich gelernt habe, für den KND, den Kurznachrichtendienst, Twitter. Das fand ich einen sehr schönen Tweet.
Ja, ja, da sind wir auch immer sehr schnell mit der Informationslieferung.
An ein breites Faktikum.
Wenn eine Überprüfung ist, muss natürlich manchmal drunter leiden.
Ich finde das Ganze einfach ein Fremdkörper im demokratischen Prozess, sowohl als Auslandsinstrument als auch als Inlandsinstrument. Ich sehe es für den Bereich der Streitkräfte noch eher als sinnvoll an, dass man sagt, man muss halt auch das eigene Personal schützen. Man sieht ja, dass die Gefährdungslage nicht abstrakt, sondern sehr konkret ist, wobei dann eher die Frage ist, warum sind wir da, was tun wir da? Warum steht die Bundeswehr am Hindukusch? Dass aber die Gefährdungslage dort vorhanden ist, weil es Menschen gibt, die die Soldaten da nicht gern sehen, ist auch klar.
Wobei du ja jetzt nicht dachrichtendienstliche Tätigkeit als solche in Frage stellst, weil man braucht ja Informationen, um auf Basis von guter Intelligenz auch Entscheidungen fällen zu können. Sondern die Problematik ist eigentlich nur die Geheimhaltung.
Ja, und auch die, also sowohl die Geheimhaltung der Informationen, die man sammelt, als auch in der Vorstufe schon die Annahme der Vertraulichkeit der Informationen. Ich halte mich da immer an den Leitspruch, den mir Wao beigebracht hat. Private Daten schützen, öffentliche Daten nützen. Und genau das ist ja der Unterschied. Diese Schwelle bricht ja einen Nachrichtendienst auf, weil er Informationen sammelt, die nicht für einen öffentlichen Kreis bestimmt sind. Und ich unterscheide sie ja klar zwischen Informationen, die ich nach außen geben will und solchen, die ich nicht will. Und ich nehme Vertraulichkeit an, wenn ich zum Beispiel mit dir bei einer Tasse Kaffee spreche. Wenn ich das aber tue, während wir diese komischen Kopfhörer auf dem Kopf haben, nehme ich an, dass es sich um ein öffentliches Gespräch handelt.
Kann man von ausgehen.
Immerhin streamen wir es nicht, wir können auch mal reinhören.
Genau, der Teil wird gestrichen.
Streichen Sie diesen Satz. Mein konkreter Ansatz ist, dass es Sinn macht, Informationen zu sammeln. Ich glaube auch daran, dass es Sinn macht, aus öffentlichen Quellen Informationen zu sammeln. Und es gibt einige wenige Bereiche, wo es Sinn macht, auch aus nichtöffentlichen Quellen zu sammeln. Wobei die Frage immer sein muss, was ist die Gefährdung, die man demjenigen zukommen lässt, der einem diese Informationen zukommen lässt. Und was macht man mit dieser Informationen? Und wie geht man damit um? Ein schönes Beispiel ist ein Film von 1973, Three Days of Condor, der ist wirklich großartig.
Das ist nicht irgendwie die drei Tage des Condor?
Robert Redford liest Bücher für die CIA.
Wo sie gleich alle erschossen werden am Anfang und so, ne?
Jetzt verrätst du zwar den Plot, aber wenn man sich angucken will, ist es wirklich ganz am Anfang. Und die Frage ist halt, was macht man mit den gewonnen Informationen? Und was ist sozusagen ein nationales Interesse? Kann es das geben? Wie kann sich das formieren? Kann sich das in direktdemokratischen Experimenten irgendwie anders formieren? Ich glaube schon, dass die Schweiz zum Beispiel lange Zeit Prozesse hat, um auf kommunaler Ebene das kommunale Interesse zu formieren und zu diskutieren. Das war zwar auch ein Mehrheitsentscheid, aber es war zumindest möglich, so was zu formieren. Wie weit es in einem Land wie den Vereinigten Staaten möglich ist, das nationale Interesse festzulegen. Oder ob es dann doch das Interesse der Ölkonzerne ist, über gewisse Prozesse in gewissen Ländern, um dort einzugreifen. Das ist halt die spannende Frage.
Was ist denn also deine Idee? Ich meine, wenn man jetzt mal ganz mutig ist und so ein neues Gesellschaftsbild bemüht und sagt, okay, wir haben jetzt ja in der Öffentlichkeit verpflichtetes Staatsprinzip. Und auch wenn wir das in Teilen sicherlich auch bereits haben und verwirklicht haben über die Zeit, gibt es da Nachbesserungsbedarf, insbesondere was eben diese Geheimdienste betrifft. Wie viel Prozent der Tätigkeit, der heute unter Geheimhaltungsprinzipien erstellten Informationsgewinnung kann eben auch auf einem anderen Prinzip erfolgen.
Das kann ich nicht beurteilen, weil ich nicht weiß, dass sie jetzt Informationen sammeln.
Da kann es dann sein, dass sie dir, wenn du dann mal wirklich gezielt nachfragst und so lange klopft, dass sie dann irgendwann mal die Tür öffnen und sagen so ja Herr Lehner, dann kommen sie doch mal rein und dann zeigen wir ihnen hier einen Film. Gibt es diesen schönen Witz von Behix? Ich glaube, ich hatte den auch irgendwann schon mal hier so als Intro, so der neue Präsident wird gewählt, also bezieh es natürlich auf die USA, der neue Präsident wird gewählt und als erstes kommen dann irgendwie so die Herren und bitten ihnen in so einen Raum und dann wird die Leidenwarte ausgerollt und ein Film fängt an und dann wird dann halt die Erschießung von John F. Kennedy gezeigt, aber aus einem bisher komplett nicht bekannten Winkel gefilmt und danach wird er dann wieder entlassen und er weiß, was zu tun ist. Das ist immer die Frage, in dem Moment, wo man sich in solchen Strukturen befindet, gewinnt man auf einmal eine Information, die man so bisher noch gar nicht kannte und das ändert alles.
Das führt ja auch dazu, dass der Umgang von politischen Entscheidungsträgern mit anderen sich ändert. Aus diesem Bewusstsein heraus, ich weiß ja eh was, was du nicht weißt und nicht wissen kannst, nicht wissen darfst. Also muss ich dir nicht zuhören, weil du hast eh keine Ahnung, was auch so zu einer gewissen Abschottung führt und eher auch eine Abhängigkeit dann von den Diensten. Das ist in der Literatur beschrieben, wie stark ausgeprägt es vorkommt, aber es klingt mir sehr plausibel. Es ist einfach ein schlüssiges Konzept zu sagen, na ja, das kann mein Gegenüber nicht wissen. Ich verlasse mich nicht mehr auf die Informationen, die ich habe, was bald auch so eine gewisse Auslieferung ist, wenn du die Quelle möglicherweise nicht kennst.
Damit haben wir ja dann implizit auch eine Verlagerung der Macht und damit eigentlich auch eine Verlagerung der eigentlichen demokratischen Machtstrukturen, so wie wir sie meinen, dass sie sind, hin in Bereiche, wenn auch jetzt nicht vollständig, ich will jetzt nicht unterstellen, dass wir irgendwie der Mittel der Geheimdienste sind und sie irgendwie alles lenken, ja, im Verschwörungsbereich, da lernt man auch schnell, also ich denke, damit würde man sie auch überschätzen.
Ja, in der Tat.
Trotz alledem gibt es da halt etwas untransparentes, unklares und das macht einen irgendwie auch immer ein bisschen skeptisch. Das ist natürlich auch so ein Problem, das Geheime produziert natürlich dann auch schnell Verschwörungstheorien, die in das beliebige steigern, weil es ja auch niemanden gibt, der ihnen Einhalt gebieten kann, so nach dem Motto, ist ja gar nicht so, weil man eben auch in diese Informationen nicht rankommt. Das kann aber dann die Gesellschaft wiederum in eine andere Richtung zerreißen. In den USA habe ich manchmal so den Eindruck, dass die Spaltung in der Hinsicht, wer so dem Staat traut und nicht traut, auch massiv ist.
Da ist das Problem, was wir hier einfach nicht haben, dass es gezielte Aktionen gibt, auch Tötungsdelikte durch die Dienste, also Operationen, nachrichtendienstliche Operationen, mit dem Zielpolitik zu verändern. Und ich weiß nicht, ob der Bundesnachrichtendienst über Personal verfügt, die sowas tun. Oder ob sie es wollen würden, aber ich kann es mir eigentlich nicht vorstellen, wären es zum Beispiel ja über den südafrikanischen Geheimdienst zur Zeit der Apartheid ganz klare Belege gibt, was die in ihren Giftlabors erforscht haben, um Oppositionelle auszuschalten. Und es ist natürlich auch immer die Frage nach der Staatsform, also wenn man sich einfach nur im Kalten Krieg Bundesrepublik Deutschland und DDR anschaut, dann ist ja die Totalität, die das Ministerium für Staatssicherheit erreicht hat, auf gar keinen Fall zu vergleichen mit dem BND. Also auch weder von der Personalstärke, noch von der Macht, noch von der finanziellen Ausstattung, noch von den Handlungsweisen.
Die Stasi haben wir jetzt komplett rausgelassen.
Da könnte man eine eigene Sendung machen.
Da müsste man auch mal eine eigene Sendung machen. Aber vielleicht mal so unter dem Aspekt, was haben wir gelernt? Denkst du, dass Lehren gezogen werden, aus dem, was sich in der DDR mit der Stasi entwickelt hat? Ist das irgendwie zu spüren oder wurde im Wesentlichen nur das Personal übernommen und hat irgendwie jetzt einen anderen Orden?
Also das Personal, was zunächst übernommen wurde, war ja das aus der Abteilung Fremde, Heere, Oster, Wehrmacht. Es gab in der Wehrmacht einen General, nämlich Reinhard Gehlen, der Leiter der Abteilung Fremde, Heere, Oster war, der Abteilung des Generalstabs und der später die nach ihm benannte Organisation Gehlen mitbegründet hat und der erster Präsident des BND war. Dieser Mann hat letztlich die Unterlagen der Abteilung Fremde, Heere, Oster auf Mikrofilm verfilmen lassen. Also all das Wissen, was die Wehrmacht über die Sowjetunion hatte, hat dieses Material Ende 1945 in die Nähe. Ja, ich habe mich von Schliersee transportieren lassen auf eine Alm, wo er sich mit seinen Mitarbeitern versteckt hat und gewartet hat, bis die ersten zwei Wellen Amerikaner durch Bayern kamen. In der Annahme, dass die Fronttruppen sicherlich keine nachrichtendienstliche Qualifikation hätten und darauf gewartet hat, bis Personen von hinreichend hohem Rang und Ausbildung kämen, denen er dieses Material offerieren könnte, in Antizipation eines Blockkonflikts zwischen Sowjetunion und Vereinigten Staaten. Also dem heranahmenden Kalten Krieg. Das sahen die zunächst anders und haben ihn in einen Kriegsgefangenenlager gesperrt, bis die Sowjetunion nach ihm suchte und ihnen dann bewusst wurde, hey, der sitzt doch bei uns. Worauf sie ihn in die Vereinigten Staaten ausgeflogen haben und mit ihm versucht haben herauszufinden, was kann man mit diesem Material machen. Und dann letztlich klar war, diese Organisation wird überführt in eine Dienststelle der Amerikaner. Das war die Organisation Gehlen, die also mit dem Materialbestand der Abteilung Fremder, Heere, Ost, der Wehrmacht, also des Generalstabs in der Lage war, Informationen über dieser Wertunion, über Truppenstärken, über Truppenbewegungen, über Infrastruktur wie Eisenbahnlinien, Umschlagbahnhöfe etc. Auskunft zu geben. Und das entsprechend aufzuarbeiten, nachzuarbeiten und fortzuführen unter der Ägide der Regierung der Vereinigten Staaten und der CIA als Partnerdienst. Und dieser Dienst wurde dann am 1. April 1956 in den Bundesnachrichtendienst überführt, weswegen deren Gründung sozusagen immer ein April-Scherz ist. Das führt natürlich auch dazu, dass versucht wurde, Personen mit einzubeziehen, die aus dem ehemaligen Kreis kamen und damit, also aus dem Umfeld kamen und damit denen auch Bekannte waren, was natürlich dazu führte, dass es auch mögliche Kriegsverbrecher in den Dienst geschafft haben. Dazu gab es eine interne Untersuchung, die dann allerdings abgewirkt wurde und für 40 Jahre oder so im Schrank verschwand. Letztlich hat das aber sicherlich den Dienst geprägt, dieses Personal zusammen mit amerikanischem Training, das wir erhalten haben, und dazu geführt hat, dass bei der weiteren Akquise von Personal immer natürlich auch Personen aus dem näheren Umfeld herangezogen wurden, nach dem Motto, mein Cousin kann viel besser Kurier spielen, weil ihn kenne ich gut. Was anfangs dazu führte, dass es auch so ein bisschen Familienversorgungswerk war. Und diese Bunkermentalität hat sich dann aber auch auf eine Art lange fortgesetzt, dass also die Seilschaften dort immer auch versucht haben, wieder ihre Leute nachzuziehen und ihre Macht- und Ränkespiele da spielten und versucht haben, das einfach beizubehalten, diese Machtposition. Und letztlich hat sich das sicherlich nach 90 geändert. Ich denke, dass relativ wenige Mitarbeiter des Ministeriums für Stadtsicherheit übernommen wurden.
Also beim BND übernommen wurden.
Beim BND übernommen wurden.
Vielleicht bei anderen auch.
Und gerade weil die Vereinigten Staaten die Personalkarteien vorher hatten und sich damit auch aussuchen konnten, wen sie gerne behalten würden. Und die sicherlich sehr viele übernommen haben. Das Stichwort ist die Rosenholzkartei, bzw. F103 glaube ich. Ja, da habe ich mal ganz einen Haufen Links zu, die wir dann noch in die Linkliste packen können. F22 für das Formblatt, Entschuldigung.
Das heißt, du meinst von der Stasi sind jetzt mehr bei amerikanischen Diensten gelandet als bei deutschen?
Das ist schwer zu quantifizieren, aber zumindest sind sie bei den Amerikanern gelandet. Und ich weiß nicht, wie viele bei den deutschen Diensten gelandet sind oder wie viele man davon misstraut hatten.
Sie sind aber nicht mehr auf der CD.
Soweit ich das verstanden habe, dann müssen wir noch mal Helmut Müller-Innenbergs interviewen.
Ja, aber sich das Interessanteste rausgebürstet und die Deutschen haben dann sozusagen diese Realität, dass da Leute gewirkt haben, gar nicht mehr mitbekommen.
Wobei es ohnehin immer die Frage ist, wie weit das vorher vollständig war oder wie weit es nicht Personen gab, die ohnehin da nicht verfügbar waren. Und dann kommen wir zu dem, das hatten wir noch gar nicht, das sollten wir vielleicht mal separat machen, weil wir den Kalten Krieg jetzt auch weitgehend ausgeblendet haben, was sozusagen klandestine Kriegsführung ist. Was ich denke, was sich gewandelt hat, ist ab Ende der 1990er Jahre, wo sukzessive den Präsidenten im Bundesnachrichtendienst einfach der Wunsch nach einer Transformation und in Teilen auch Öffnungen innewohnte, vermutlich auch, um überhaupt eine Rechtfertigung für das Bestehen zu haben. Weil der primäre Existenzzweck gab es ja nicht mehr. Was wir auch in den Vereinigten Staaten beobachten, wo halt der primäre Existenzzweck jetzt nicht mehr die Sowjetunion ist, sondern offensichtlich der Terrorismus.
Also der Anti-Terror-Dienste oder der CIA etc. Beziehungsweise, was sie ja auch selber sagen, einfach der Schutz und Förderung ihrer wirtschaftlichen Interessen weltweit.
Das ist ohnehin eine Wirtschaftskreisführung.
Was ja auch ein ehemaliger Bundespräsident in Deutschland mal zum Besten gegeben hat.
Ja, da war er noch, ist noch gar nicht so lange her. Nichtsdestotrotz hat sich insbesondere ab 1996 viel geändert unter Hansjörg Geiger, der auch Staatssekretär im Justizministerium war, der einfach versucht hat, eine größere Offenheit herzustellen. Unter anderem hatte das Schild Behördenunterkunft durch eine Leuchtreklamme im Bundesnachrichtendienst ersetzen lassen gegen größere Widerstände im Haus. Was scheint da vorher drauf? Behördenunterkunft.
Behördenunterkunft anstatt Bundesnachrichtendienst.
Und auf den Schildern, die das Fotografieren mit Geldstrafe von 10.000 Mark bedrohten, die es noch in einem Sternenartikel geben müsste, in dem es ein paar Bilder gab, stand Wehrbereichsverwaltung Süd-Schutzbereichsbehörde. Was auch wieder so eine plausibel klingende Tarnbezeichnung ist, bis man irgendjemand fragt, der sich mit der Struktur der Bundeswehr auskennt und scheinend lacht. Also es ist schon immer mehr so für den Uneingeweihten als Legendierung gedacht. Nichtsdestotrotz hat der halt versucht, auch eine größere Öffnung hinzubekommen. Und ich denke, seither hat sich auch viel im Rekrutierungsverhalten getan. Das heißt, das Personal, das jetzt eingestellt wird, wird offensichtlich eher nach Leistungen beurteilt als nach verwandtschaftlichen Beziehungen zu existierendem Personal.
Was sich positiv hätte auswirken können.
Genau, ob es das tut, wissen wir ja nicht. Wissen wir ja nicht.
Weil es ist ja geheim. Ja, das macht es auch ein bisschen schwierig, darüber zu reden in gewisser Hinsicht. Aber das ist ja auch so in der ganzen Sache.
Ja, wir haben ja so ein Annähern durch Dialog und mal gucken, ob sich irgendwas ergibt.
Der Hans-Jörg Geiger war aber, ist richtig, ich sehe auch, beim Verfassungsschutz mal Präsident.
Der war, glaube ich, auch beim Verfassungsschutz Präsident, für aber auch nicht lange. Ich glaube, der war ein Jahr lang Präsident im BFV und dann zwei Jahre lang knapp im BND und ist dort dann ins Justizministerium wegbelobigt worden. So, letztlich lässt sich aber festhalten, es ist ein sehr schwieriges Feld im Bereich der grundsätzlichen Frage, wie funktioniert die Transformation zur Wissens- und Informationsgesellschaft? Wie funktioniert Freiheit von Informationen? Wie weit steht das zum Beispiel der Club-Forderung nach einer maschinenlesbaren Regierung entgegen? Wie sinnvoll ist das Produkt, das dort generiert wird? Ist es das Geld wert, was dafür aufgewendet wird? Kann man das nicht mit anderen Mitteln machen, die möglicherweise weniger invasiv sind, die möglicherweise kostengünstiger sind? Und wie kann man es schaffen, das zu bewerten? Also was sind die Maßstäbe, anhand derer man das bewerten kann? Und wer in der politischen Führung kann das bewerten? Und wie weit kann das die Regierung und wie weit kann das insbesondere das Parlament künftig leisten? Und welche Änderungen muss man dafür herbeiführen und erwirken? Und ich denke, das ist aber eine Aufgabe, die sich die Dienste stellen müssen. Und derer sich auch insbesondere stellen müssen.
Dann würde ich jetzt ganz gerne so zum Schluss noch mal gerne auf den Anfang zurückkommen und zwar so deine persönliche Motivation. Du hast ja gesagt, du hast dich mit vielen beschäftigt und am Ende hast du Politikwissenschaften studiert. Wer jetzt ähnlich drauf ist und sich sozusagen mal hier für das System interessiert. Ich meine, wir hätten diese ganze Diskussion jetzt auch unter ganz anderen Vorzeichen führen können. Wir hätten jetzt hier groß die Keule auspacken können, Verschwörungstheorie hin, Verschwörungstheorie her, die bösen Geheimdienste und so weiter. Da ist man ja auch mal schnell dabei. Ich denke, das ist auch klar geworden. Den Ton haben wir irgendwie so nicht so richtig, weil es ist ja letzten Endes auch immer eine Frage der kritischen Begleitung mit einer Perspektive von Lösungsansätzen. Du studierst Politikwissenschaften. Was lernt man da? Oder was ist bei dir in diesem gesamten Prozess unabhängig jetzt auch von dem Studium? Darum geht es mir jetzt gar nicht so sehr. Also sozusagen mit der Auseinandersetzung des Systems, des Staates, der Organisation, dieser Gesellschaft de facto. Was setzt da bei dir ein in dem Moment, wo du dich damit beschäftigst und wo so eben auch solche konfliktbeladenen Teilbereiche sichtbar werden? Zweifelt man da irgendwie am System? Verlebt man da sozusagen den Mut, sich überhaupt zu engagieren? Ist das eigentlich eher so ein Bereich, in dem man auch eine ganze Menge bewegen kann? Oder ist das irgendwie alles total verfahren? Gibt es da einen Mangel an guten Leuten, die alle bei Web 2.0-Startups hingeblieben sind, obwohl sie sich eigentlich lieber mal dort systemhackend hätten einbringen können?
Also der initiale Wandel ist sicherlich das Bewusstsein, dass ich habe, dass es das gelobte Land auf Erden ist. Das hatte ich ja schon mal in einem Kongressvortrag über Anonymizer erzählt, als Julius und ich unsere Erfahrungen über den Umgang mit polizei- und Staatsanwaltschaften berichteten. Und das ist sicherlich was, was ich mit 14 anders gesehen habe, was vielleicht auch aus meinem Umgang in der Zeit herrühren mag. Da war ich halt auch viel mit den Paranoikern des Klubs verbandelt.
Institut für Paranoik.
Hervorragend. Abteilung für... Gesellschaft für abweichende Sichtweisen. Ich glaube inzwischen, dass ich...
Das gelobte Land ist eine große Worte.
Ja, aber ich meine, das ist keine Systemopposition im Sinne eines Abschaffens des Systems. Und ich glaube, dass sich das reformieren lässt. Ich glaube noch, immer noch und auch immer mehr, wenn ich mir anschaue, was die Instrumente sind, die man zur Verfügung hat, dass man das so weit umbauen kann, dass es ein modernes Staatswesen ist und dass es die Mehrheitsmeinung widerspiegelt. Aber ich glaube auch, dass sehr viel schief läuft. Aber einer der Aspekte ist, man kann offen drüber sprechen. Das ist was, was ich bei all dem, auch im Studium auch davor immer gelernt habe. Du kannst mit jedem drüber sprechen, und zwar auch mit den höchsten Entscheidungsträgern. Du kannst dich mit dem Innenstaatssekretär hinsetzen, du kannst ihm sogar ins Gesicht sagen, dass du glaubst, dass es Machtmissbrauch in den folgenden Bereichen gab. Und du kriegst nicht aufs Maul. Und die sagen, ja, das ist eine interessante Anregung, aber... Und dann gehst du noch mal in die Bibliothek und guckst dir vergleichende historische Fälle ansprichst mit ein paar Leuten und stellst fest, naja, okay, das ist nicht so gravierend, wie der Fall, mit dem du es verglichen hast, aber der existiert tatsächlich. Und die Frage ist sozusagen, wie kann man all das verbessern? Wie kann man schrittweise Verbesserungen herbeiführen? Und was davon ist Transparenz? Und ich glaube halt, dass offene Kommunikation über das, die offene Debatte eigentlich das konstitutive Merkmal schlechthin in der Demokratie ist. Wir müssen über den Scheiß reden. Es ist ja nicht so, dass meine Meinung jetzt mehr zählt als die eines anderen. Es ist auch nicht so, als ob ich die durchsetzen möchte, komme, was wolle. Ich weiß es ja auch nicht, aber ich würde es gerne mit anderen Leuten diskutieren und deren Sichtweisen sehen, zum Teil annehmen oder eben auch nicht. Aber genau das ist dieser Aushandlungsprozess. Und das ist etwas, was mich am allermeisten stört, was ich beobachten kann, dass das immer weniger der Fall ist. Vielleicht ist es auch nur ein Wahrnehmungsphänomen, dass jetzt, wo man immer mehr Einblick gewinnen kann, man den Eindruck hat, dass es immer weniger funktioniert. Auf der anderen Seite selbst diese tiefe Verunsicherung im bürgerlichen Lager. Was machen wir mit dem Präsidenten? Hoch erst weg, kriegen wir einen neuen? Was passiert hier eigentlich? Selbst das führt ja dazu, dass es auch so ein bisschen an die Ränder wandert. Und das ist ein Problem, was ich hab, dass zum Beispiel die großen Volksparteien, wenn man sich die Nicht-Wähler mit anguckt, wäre Schwarz, Rot, Gelb unter 50 Prozent bei der letzten Bundestagswahl. Also nur ganz knapp. Aber die repräsentieren nicht mal mehr in einer übergroßen Koalition de facto den Willen des Volkes. Und das ist halt ein Problem. Und auf der anderen Seite, wenn Entscheidungen getroffen werden, werden die oftmals offensichtlich für andere Interessen getroffen. Woher auch immer dieser Druck kommt, sei es das Spielen über Bande mit Brüssel. Aber ganz oft habe ich den Eindruck, hier werden Dinge umgesetzt, die niemand will. Und trotzdem, sei es die Fraktionsdisziplin oder was auch immer, der ausschlaggebende Faktor hier ist, trotzdem finden die ja statt. Und das ist ein Riesenproblem. Und was sind sozusagen die übergeordneten Interessen, die das mandatieren? Wie kann man das offenlegen? Und welche Rolle spielen da zum Beispiel auch die Dienste? Ich weiß nicht, was deren Interesse ist, aber ganz offensichtlich ist diese mangelnde Transparenz und dieses Durchdrücken von oben und dieses Demokratiedefizit ein Riesenproblem und dem können wir eigentlich nur durch Transparenz entgegnen, durch offene Kommunikationen, was auch immer die Instrumente dafür sein werden, wie auch immer direkt demokratische Beteiligung stattfinden kann. Jetzt haben wir historisch in Deutschland lange Zeit den Fall gehabt, dass eigentlich niemand auf Ebene der politischen Führung dem Volk vertraut und dass es auch Systemimmanent war, dass dem Volk nicht vertraut wird in ganz vielen Fragen. Was okay ist aus der historischen Erfahrung und ja trotzdem funktioniert hat, die Leute waren ja dennoch zufrieden. Inzwischen habe ich aber den Eindruck, dass es sich einfach gewandelt hat, dass also immer mehr Menschen auf der Performanzebene mit der Leistung des Systems unzufrieden sind, man aber ihnen immer mehr vertrauen könnte, weil sie sich offensichtlich immer stärker auch mit den Inhalten auseinandersetzen, mit den Modi auseinandersetzen und ja auch konkrete Vorschläge machen. Ich denke, die Geröhnung der Piratenpartei war ein hervorragendes Moment, um das auch in andere Parteien hineinzutragen. Also zum Beispiel diese Enquete-Kommissionen, was auch immer die bringen mag. Ich denke, da werden gerade sehr viele Chancen verschenkt. Nichtsdestotrotz hätte die vermutlich ohne die Piratenpartei in dieser Form nicht stattgefunden. Nicht, dass die Piratenpartei eine Lösung ist. Die haben, glaube ich, einen Frauenanteil, der geringer ist als Gay-Romeo. Aber so eine Dating-Plattform. Also daran müssen die noch arbeiten. Auch die Altersverteilung ist eine Katastrophe. Aber immerhin haben sie eine sehr respektable Leistung gezeigt. Und jetzt ist die Frage, wie kann man das auf Dauer stellen? Und ist es möglich, so etwas, was die Grünen geleistet haben für die Umwelt und die neuen sozialen Bewegungen, kann man so etwas nicht auch für die Informationsgesellschaft leisten? Und wie weit kann also sozusagen im offenen Dialog, und das denke ich ist das Schlusswort, wie weit kann im offenen Dialog aufgrund der Informationen, die wir über uns und die Welt haben, eine neue Politik entstehen, eine Zielrichtung entstehen? Wo möchte die Gesellschaft insgesamt hin? Und was sind die Instrumentarien, um das zu erreichen? Und wie setzt man das um?
Ja, ich lass das offen. Die Antworten hab ich auch nicht. Aber die können sich erfinden lassen. Vielleicht habt ihr ja Lust beizutragen zu der Lösungsfindung. Jeder draußen, die ihr immer so bis zum bitteren Ende hier auch zuhört. Was haben wir jetzt gehabt hier? Naja, immerhin wieder über zwei Stunden. Informationen zu Nachrichtendiensten und sonstigen Eigenschaften unseres Staats- und Gemeinwesens.
Gerne. Hoffentlich sehen wir uns dieses Mal wieder schneller als in zwei Jahren.
Genau, oder zweieinhalb, wie viel es war. Ja, an mir liegt es nicht. Die Metaebene ist sendebereit. Das Institut für Sprachverbreitung. Das ist großartig, ich glaube, da kann man irgendwie reiten. Also für Sprachforscher wäre da wahrscheinlich schon eine ganze Menge zu finden. Okay, jetzt machen wir aber Schluss.